Keep joints in it,
but it's not quite big enough.
The holes.
Oh yeah.
Cause they come out like all bent and
sad.
We're live.
Yeah.
I tried to keep joints in there,
but it didn't just stay put in there.
It all kind of were like,
it was like half on half smushed.
We need like one of those bubblegum
brains.
You can just sticking it in there.
Yeah.
Uh,
I didn't want a fanboy out when I met
you,
but I'm a huge fan.
I really love your music.
I think Dave Cross,
it was the first guy who turned me onto
you,
I think.
Yeah.
I don't remember how I met.
Just remember him telling me about exile
in Guyville.
Do you mean Mr showed?
Yeah.
Yeah,
he's the one.
He was a big Mr Show was in my happiest
touring iteration.
Like that was what we watched every
night after the show we'd hit the bus
and everyone would watch mister show
tilly passed out.
That's a genius show.
I think it's like for Bob and Bob
Degrade on better call Saul and breaking
bad and has done a lot of other stuff.
That's awesome too.
But there's something about the two of
those guys together.
Yeah,
very unusual combination.
And they're writing,
it's just so bizarre and weird.
But they did a netflix thing for awhile.
I don't know if there are they still
doing that,
do you know?
I think he's doing those other shows
now.
I don't think so.
Too Bad.
Anyway,
Dave Cross introduce me to Liz phair.
Well I am,
that's a nice,
that's a nice touchstone since it was
part of my touring.
Yeah,
there you go.
I feel very good about that.
So you got,
what do you have now?
You have a box set out coming up
compilation.
Is that what it means?
It's kind of like a,
it's a reissue of my first record exile
in Guyville.
Um,
with the original girlies sound tapes
that I made on a four track in Ga late
eighties,
early nineties.
Is that when you were living at home?
Yeah,
that was when I was recalled back from
San Francisco having not gotten a job
and run out of money and grifting my way
across like the bay area.
Um,
I mean I had a place,
we,
I was rooming,
everyone from my college class moved out
to San Francisco basically from Oberlin.
I went to,
and I made these little cassettes that I
forwarded to two friends and one of them
got super busy making copies of these
cassettes and sent them to every fanzine
in America with this like glowing
recommendation.
And all of a sudden I was getting,
I was living at home,
um,
still didn't have a job and I would get
these envelopes coming to me saying
like,
please make me a cassette copy.
Here's $10.
Can you imagine what happened to the
$10?
How awful is that?
I truly just like,
I was like,
great,
thanks.
I wasn't making it.
Yeah.
Like there's about a hundred people that
didn't get their cassette,
but I wasn't making in the cassette.
But anyway,
that's sort of Taijuan you is actually
the person who made lots of cassettes
and sent them around.
So I have him to thank,
did you have a thought
that you were going to eventually make
it or be a big singer or the g?
Was that even an idea?
Not a clue.
I cleaned it.
Being in front of people like I would
not want to.
I loved being in the studio.
I loved recording but I didn't,
I was super stage frightened and I
couldn't think of anything.
I'd rather do less and get up in front
of you or play music or do anything
really.
Yeah,
absolutely.
Wow.
But it is hard,
but you obviously have a love of music.
I love playing music.
I just,
I get very self conscious with a group
called this sucker up to you.
Otherwise we're not going to,
I get very self conscious in front of
crowds.
Still not so much anymore.
I do about two weeks before I hit the
stage,
I will stop sleeping and then really to
work myself into this kind of cold
sweat.
When I think about it,
I'll be like,
can I leave the country?
And then like I get on the stage and it
all comes back to me and I'm like,
I've done this a million times.
This is the best job in the world.
And it just,
it,
I can't psych myself into that feeling
until I'm actually on stage.
Maybe that's just cause you care about
it so much.
Probably I'm too alert.
We should be smoking those joints that
are not in own head.
I have some over here.
I know.
Can't even imagine where we'd go with
that.
We do it all the time.
She want to do,
let me know.
We're about 10 minutes and he changed
your mind.
I can time.
It gets really rough,
but it gets really personal.
Maybe sometimes you have to and I'm
just,
I'm a very awake person.
Hmm.
Well that's a good thing.
That's,
that's uh,
the more sensitive you are though,
the more you have to consider all the
possibilities and that that's what could
keep you up.
Right.
To send you down the UFO wormhole.
We talked about that
cast.
Yeah.
There's this guy that's coming on.
His name is doctor Robert Schoch can
easy geologists from Boston University
and he's worked on,
there's,
uh,
some real scientists that believe it's
entirely possible that the sphinx and a
lot of the construction in Egypt is far
older than they think
I know all about,
all about know about Robert Shaw runoff
and erosion has occurred around the base
or around the pit that the,
and it absolutely couldn't have been
done depending on like the way the
Sphinx is built where it's located.
This sighting.
Yeah.
Where it's level is,
is far older.
So
yes,
they think it was somewhere in the
neighborhood of 9,000 plus bc because
that's the law.
When back then the Nile Valley was a
rain forest and somehow or another it
became a desert.
And um,
this guy's,
you know,
legit Boston University professor,
geologist,
and he's traveling all over the place,
but he's here for some Ufo conference
and the Ufo people wanted to him to
mention the UFO conference.
And I'm like,
fucking Christ with Ufo conferences,
you guys don't have anything.
If you had something that would be,
what are you gonna get in a fucking
merriot somewhere and show,
show some blurry picture of some
fucking,
a hubcap to someone chucked up into the
air.
Like there's nothing.
Everything that,
everything that they look at falls apart
under scrutiny.
This is oak.
A few videos.
Okay.
I'm going to push back on.
Please do.
Let's just say,
what about,
do you know the discovery disclosure?
Yes.
Disclosure project.
Okay.
There was their first press conference
when they got all the,
I'm,
I tend to be impressed by the military,
you know,
ranking members.
I'm sort of like,
if you were,
if you were guarding missile silos and
you say you saw something hover above it
and deactivate,
you know,
I'm probably going to check that out a
little harder.
And there were just so many people that
stood up,
you know,
in that press conference and said that
they absolutely had seen evidence,
met extra terrestrials seeing the
crafts,
like in hangars,
et cetera.
Yup.
And to me,
like I,
they didn't look like they had that much
imagination.
They're the kind of people that I didn't
think could really,
I mean,
did you find that convincing at all?
No.
Here's why.
No,
no.
Just like a whole bunch of liars,
a whole line of live greer,
right?
The disclosure project so much about
him,
he doesn't appeal to me as much as the
people that he brought on who were
mostly military.
Yes.
Here's the thing about military.
Anybody who's in the military is a
person.
If you get a hundred people together,
one of them is out of their fucking
mind.
If you get a million people,
you've got a shit ton of people that are
out of their fucking mind that are
running around that one extra attention.
One of the best ways to say you're,
you are one of the best ways to get
extra tension is to say you've had some
extraordinary experience that separates
you from the pack.
It's one of the main points of delusion
that people that are really out of their
fucking mind,
well,
it won't want to point to.
I see things in people.
I can read Auras.
I can tell I'm a psychic healer.
I'm an intuitive person.
They all have this thing that separates
them from the herd without any work
whatsoever.
I feel like a lot of these people are
that they want attention and so they
tell these extraordinary stories.
Now when you said they're not creative,
that's a very astute point cause they
all the same fucking story cause it's
the same story that's been going on
forever.
They just repeat shit they've already
heard.
Most of these people I think are full of
Shit I think is entirely possible.
That UFO is a been here entirely
possible that see people have seen you
at foes entirely possible but a lot of
those people,
my fucking bullshit radar just goes off.
I paint May,
may main yeah I I've talked to too many
of them and when I did that television
show Joe Rogan questions everything and
I met with Ufo people in bigfoot people.
I was telling you before the podcast,
it cured me cause I got to be around
those people for hours and just talk to
him.
No cameras on them like,
oh,
you're fucking crazy,
or you're delusional,
or your way of looking at things is not
objective or you're talking to me
because you want to convince me of
something.
You're not just communicating the ideas
that are actually in your head.
You're pitching me some sort of a
speech.
You're like,
you've got some sort of a you're doing
for me.
I smell it,
and as a performer I smell it.
I'm like,
this is nonsense.
You telling me nonsense.
You know,
they would tell you,
well,
you want evidence,
I'll back a truck up and show you the
evidence.
I'm like,
where's your fucking evidence?
You don't have any other audit today.
I mean like,
yeah,
here's the thing.
Did they seem as off kilter in
everything else they talked about that
relationship,
relationships,
jobs,
they're all screwballs.
They're almost all screw balls.
The people that are most convincing are
the people that see these orbs flying
around the pilots.
Yeah.
Well,
the reason why they see these things is
there's a real phenomenon called ball
lightning.
It's absolutely real and it's caused by
various weather conditions and they
think that even be caused sometimes by
the right weather conditions and the
shifting of tectonic plates that somehow
or another the friction.
Yes,
and that these Bob Ball lightning,
if you've ever seen videos of it,
it's phenomenal.
It just flies around.
They've even had an inside airplanes
somehow or another ball.
Lightning has shot down the aisle of an
airplane while I was in Florida.
Have you really enlightening on a flight
that was struck by lightning?
Whoa.
He was pink and it sounded like a giant
bb gun.
Hid a tin can.
Oh yeah.
You were in a plane that was hit by
lightning.
Yes.
Holy Shit.
That's intense.
It was very intense.
I was coming off of tour and I wanted to
get back to my very young son.
I told him I'd be there in the morning
when he woke up,
so I ended up going on this odyssey like
planes,
trains and automobiles,
you know,
trying to get to them.
Right?
Like I was like,
I will be there in the morning and it
was terrible weather.
It's just like the worst on the east
coast.
And we kept taking,
I think twice we took off and had to
land before we could get to our
destination and get in the plane and go
off again.
And me being a crazy mom,
I'm like,
how can I get there?
Um,
so I get on this plane and it's very
bad.
We're flying right through with
thunderstorm.
But I've,
I've flown so many times,
I've,
my parents took me a million places.
We traveled a lot when I was young,
so I've just been flying forever and we
were on this blame,
the lightning's going off and thunder
and we're rattling around and it's not a
very big plane.
And my seat mate,
I think,
I didn't know who he was,
but he seemed like a decent,
nice young man.
And like the lightening just hit the
plane.
You get this big Tang of the,
you know,
the shock of the electricity just
hitting it.
We drop about,
I don't know what,
I don't know what makes a big stomach
drop,
but we drop far.
It's like 25 feet.
I Dunno.
Just like Bam.
And this pink ball of electricity just
goes like whoosh down the aisle.
Okay.
In the center of the aisle.
He pukes I grab
and I did not let go of this change or
just puked like until we were,
you know,
like I just,
it took about,
you know,
10 minutes and then it was like,
uh,
but that was intense and I made it,
I was there in the morning when my son
woke up,
so that's awesome.
Yeah.
But it was incredible.
The pinkness of it is still really vivid
to my mind and the ball lightning.
It was,
it was a sphere that just came wishing
down the aisle.
Wow.
That's awesome.
Lots of crazy plane.
Almost crashed stories.
What else?
Uh,
there was a time that the engine was on
fire and I could see it that you could
see it on fire.
Yeah.
Where were you please don't say over the
ocean.
Yeah,
but not far.
We were just off outside of Boston.
We took off nighttime again after a show
trying to get home to my cat.
I mean this is like this dad,
his mom's story trying to,
um,
and it was night and I was looking at
the lights,
the sort of,
I forget what they call those orange
lights and it was over the bag and see
the water and we just weren't rising
quickly enough.
You know,
it just,
I was like why,
why aren't we gaining altitude?
What's going on?
You just didn't seem right.
And someone on my left,
I was in the last row and someone on my
left said something like the engine's on
fire,
whatever,
right as the captain comes on and says,
ladies and gentlemen,
we have a problem with one of the
engines.
We are going to have to make an
emergency landing.
Please remain in your seat.
And I look over and you can literally
see flames shooting out of the,
like it,
cause the,
the engine was about 10 rows ahead of
me,
but the sparks were visible behind,
you know,
because you're,
do you understand like the physics,
so like it's a long trail is sparks
coming out of that thing.
And so we get to the point where we're
going to make our like landing and to
see the flight attendants scared
shitless was not a fun experience.
I think that frightened me the most.
Like seeing their faces and we had to
get into the crouch position,
you know,
that position,
the brace yourself position.
And the captain came on.
I think the last thing he said,
which was not reassuring was please
brace for a very rough landing.
And I'm,
I'm thinking if you're crashing it
doesn't,
you can't say anything more than that
ladies and gentlemen.
You mean like that's it.
Please prepare for a very rough landing.
And what happened?
I know I'm like monologuing but like
what happened to my body at that moment
was I went into,
it's only happened twice in my life.
Full tremors,
like full body.
Do you know,
have you ever had that?
It's different than like nervous shaking
or cold shaking.
It's like full
and your body's just like completely
vibrating,
like at another frequency.
And I realized for the first time in my
life that I didn't care if I was dead
like in two seconds.
And I felt nothing.
It really upset me that my body,
my soft squishy body,
it was going to be like pinned into
metal bugged me.
Like I really thought like we're never
doing this again like this.
It just became very,
very real that my,
that I cared about this arm and I cared
about this lag and I didn't want like it
to be completely mangled and like stuck
in metal and we hit the,
we got the ground,
it was a very rough landing and there
were firetrucks going like 110 miles an
hour on either side of us spraying us
with the d accelerant or whatever that
is,
and suddenly like foam on the windows
and are you ready for this?
So it was not a fun thing,
but we survived and no one was harmed.
And then we had to get back on another
plane because I had to go home to see my
kids.
So he literally sat there and waited and
got right back on another plane and flew
home.
Well you probably be like,
what are the odds?
No,
I just,
I wanted to see my kid.
Right.
But like that was an intense,
you mean that thing you don't ever get
to experience us unless you're like a
combat person.
Like even if you're not conscious,
I don't want this like all screwed up.
I don't want to be like mangled.
No one does.
And the reality of it was like right
there,
right there and I don't feel it anymore.
I'm just a stupid and reckless as I ever
was.
But like in that moment it was very real
to me.
You know?
Fuck,
I haven't had anything like that.
That's intense.
I don't know what's more intense getting
to hit by lightening or the fire.
They're both pretty fun.
The Cessna that lost power over the
Bermuda Triangle,
is that good?
You know what that is?
They think they think it's nitrogen
escaping from the sea floor.
They think there's trap nitrogen and
massive amounts,
you know,
cause there's a lot of like dead things
and decaying things like vegetation and
things like that.
And they trap nitrogen pockets and those
nitrogen pockets,
when they lift up,
they can go through the surface of the
water and up into the air.
And if a plane is flying into that is
methane.
Is it methane?
I say it wrong.
Yeah.
Because nitrogen is every second year.
So 84% of the air.
But I think there's something about it
being a giant pocket that you fly
through.
I might be wrong.
You're talking about the gap in the tech
tonic.
It's methane.
Yeah.
And it can like make a ship go down
because yeah.
Suddenly there's no downside.
There's no buoyancy for the ships and
also for planes.
It makes,
could be,
yeah.
Okay.
This is most explosions explaining it
for me to try it.
Yeah.
We can google.
Oh my God.
This is how we roll it.
I'm never leaving.
Come state.
You can come anytime you want.
This is incredible.
We can come and just talk about Ufo was
over a week.
Oh my God.
This is incredible.
Explosions of trapped methane gas are
thought to account for the mysterious
critters in Siberia,
including this one.
Yeah.
And so they think that has to do
something with the Bermuda Triangle as
well.
So when biological tissue creates
methane and,
um,
when they have like massive amounts of
die off,
whether it's fish or whether it's plants
or things like that,
they think that some of that stuff gets
trapped in the bottom of the sea floor
and then escapes goes up to the surface,
makes boats sink and even can bring down
planes.
How did it make a plain because plain
flat,
Oh,
I dunno.
Really lost electricity.
What'd you hear that hear a plane lost
electricity.
And that's what I thought.
Oh,
you were in it started again.
that could've just been a shitty plane.
He was that much.
That sounds like a dried,
I'm sure that violet absolutely told us
that.
You know what I mean?
Like he's like,
ah,
get the,
the,
the stuff gets a little fritzy up here
over the Bermuda triangle.
We're buying it.
It's just a shitty lane.
And he didn't like the service or,
you know,
oh my God,
Joe,
you just killed my story.
I might be naive in believing that.
Like this whole thing
don't,
no,
it's just a shitty plane.
Could be shit.
They'll still play in the shitty.
Yeah.
That's what they think.
That's the most prevalent theory,
I would think.
You'd die if that bubble hit you just
from a lot of it,
right?
Yeah.
Maybe.
Have you ever seen those underwater
lakes of methane?
That's creepy.
All right,
so water underwater,
right?
Yeah.
No,
it's the ocean is amazing.
It's pretty bizarre that it's just right
there,
that it's essentially an alien world.
Like I've always said,
like the ocean is really like space,
like spaces like above us all the time,
but the ocean is kind of just like
space.
If it's right there,
you can go in and that's a whole nother
world.
It's like a whole nother world.
It's on our earth,
but we're just so used to it.
It's like,
Oh yeah,
let's go surfing.
Hey,
let's get in the boat.
Floating around some fucking alien
world.
It's right there.
It's filled with life.
All sorts of life.
That actually breeds water like yeah,
came from,
yeah.
Well,
I was talking about it with my,
Oh,
is that the lakes of methane underwater?
That's nuts.
It's so God damn,
that is crazy.
They're like,
I'm going to go by the lake.
I just took a run around the shore.
That doesn't even look real.
It's like they're going around silver
lake.
That's that email is just like cruising
around silver lake,
but it's a methane lake.
What was that movie where like is
probably a methane lake too,
but it's been in other ways.
Yeah.
What was that movie where there was
aliens underwater?
The abyss.
Oh yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
Drowned to survive any us to re assess
the tater.
Yeah.
Right,
and they were like aliens was assumed.
The shape of water.
What's it called?
Aliens and the deep,
hmm.
I think it's probably the best though.
I think it's the best and they were sort
of pink too.
They were the same colors.
My ball lightning.
Remember that pink from the,
yeah.
The only guy that ever talked to when I
was talking to this Ufo people that I
believed about,
Ufos was a guy who was that skin walker
ranch.
That whole area out there has a shitload
of Ufo sightings,
scanning locker,
ranch.
It's some place that
this Guy Robert Bigelow owns and he is
an,
what makes it compelling is he actually
is an aerospace investor and he's got a
company that makes all these parts and
shit for different spaceships and
different pods and things too.
Why?
Why does he do immune?
It's his business,
but he also owns this gigantic ranch in
Utah and we went out to visit them,
visit the ranch and visit some of the
people around there that,
and one guy that we talked to that lived
around there was just regular dude.
I think he worked in a factory,
just regular guy,
not crazy,
but super normal.
Like talk to him,
not a bullshit artist at all.
And he's telling me about this glowing
orb that came through the walls of his
house and,
and floated around inside of his living
room and kitchen and then took off
through the wall.
And I said,
ah,
like the way he described it,
I absolutely believe that he was telling
me the truth and I think that was ball
lightning.
I think we have it a lot in that area.
And so I think whatever the atmosphere
conditions in that area,
it's a frequent occurrence.
And because of that,
a lot of these people see things and
they start talking and then people start
looking for him and then they start
talking crazy and then people start
talking about like they were talking
about a bullet proof wolf that appeared
out of mist.
And like for real,
that was like an got that out front.
Oh,
the Werewolf greeter.
Yeah.
But this,
this guy was the only guy that made
sense and I think he saw ball lightning
just like you did.
How could it be on the ground?
Like that
could just happen,
you know,
if there's a storm conditions,
but it does,
it occurs not just up in the sky.
It occurs at low altitude as well.
Yeah,
they say ball.
They don't know why.
But apparently I talked to a scientist
about this.
He was telling me that lightning
shouldn't be possible.
Like there's,
there's shouldn't be enough power to
create lightning.
There's like,
if you do the calculations,
he's like,
but clearly we know it's true.
So what do we do about that?
We don't really know.
We don't know enough about lightening.
So when you describe ball lightning,
he's like,
well good fucking luck.
Who knows who,
what are the atmosphere?
We don't know enough about it.
Yeah.
We don't know what the conditions are
like what?
What does that mean?
There's not enough energy for
lightening.
They can't,
you can't marshal that much electricity
in the atmosphere.
I'm too stupid to repeat what he said
and have it make any sense.
But when he was describing it to me,
the way he was explaining it,
and I think I read it as well,
he was,
he was explaining and what I read was
that they don't really understand how
that much energy is produced in the sky
like that and that if you calculated
like what it would take to produce
that,
that shouldn't be possible.
Again,
I'm a moron.
No,
I,
I wished a real expert were here.
I wish I was like,
that's fascinating.
Yeah.
So he,
with this guy was described,
it was talking about ball lightning.
We were saying they don't know how to
recreate ball lightning.
They,
they have no idea what causes it.
But there are,
sure it's a real thing.
Wait,
we can't recreate ball lightning in a
lab environment.
I don't believe so.
That's crazy.
Yeah.
I don't think they can it.
You know,
you're right because we can't generate
that amount of power.
We literally can't gender,
I mean maybe with a bomb,
but we can't generate that.
I have no idea.
I think we can't.
Well,
I think that's what a lot of people are
seeing.
I think these people that see things and
then also the human imagination is so
fantastic.
Your memory's all fucked up.
Memory's terrible.
You know?
So you see something and then you
decided something different when you see
it.
I talked to another lady told me she saw
big foot and she wasn't a book.
She didn't seem like a bullshit artist.
She seemed like she was being a hundred
percent honest.
She didn't seem like she needed a ton of
attention.
She didn't seem crazy and I think she
saw bear.
I just think she saw a bear way in the
distance and she saw it very briefly
because it was the Pacific northwest and
trees are very dense,
thick.
She saw a big,
and it might even been on two legs,
cause bears do do that all the time.
And I think she saw that and in her mind
she saw a gorilla.
It was,
Whoa,
why am I looking at a gorilla?
And then she had this story that just
got concocted in her head and she saw
Saskia
that happens.
I mean,
I,
I'm convinced of certain things and then
I find out I'm completely wrong.
But you know,
it does happen.
I told you that you better back off the
ghost.
Um,
I used to believe a great deal.
I still pretty much believe pretty much,
I think basically this is my entire
philosophy on all weirdnesses okay.
If you look back 500 years to what they
knew scientifically,
then it's superstitious.
It's magic,
it's ridiculous,
it's ignorant,
et Cetera,
et cetera.
I believe that that's exactly what we
are now to 500 years in the future.
So I don't consider it paranormal.
I consider it future science goes her
future science,
go surf future science,
aliens or future science.
It's all future science.
And I'm down for that.
I'm ready to party with the future
science.
I'm ready for that.
Accept that.
Um,
my problem is the people that tell ghost
stories or those fucking go shows,
there's so,
there's so faked,
so painfully faith.
I really believed it for a while.
Like I really absolutely bought into it.
Hook,
line and sinker.
I was like,
they're watching the little there,
the,
there's all different kinds of ghosts.
Like the ones that look like,
um,
he walks or none.
He walks,
which are the ones that are the jet,
the first movie star wars.
And they like where they're little robes
and they were busy.
They were like,
oh,
you know the first ones that loot,
they're like,
we're selling route robotics.
I don't know.
They didn't really have faces.
They just had like cloaks the robot
sellers.
Well apparently there are ghosts that
are little cloak creatures and they
scare the crap out of me.
They move fast and I don't understand
what they're doing here.
Like,
but I mean you can explain demons.
You can explain demons.
If you think about like dog ghosts or
wolf ghosts or lion ghosts,
that's a demon.
Could be,
they growl.
They have like weird eyes.
They're hostile.
They scratch you animal.
So you,
you have a real belief in ghosts.
The treanda kind of like not 100% but,
but you're,
you have an open wide bump into them
sometimes a week.
And I don't see them but I feel them and
hear them and that like,
I know,
go ahead.
Oh little smile.
That little smile.
That's why we're talking about it.
Cause we're on the weirdness podcasts,
but like I don't talk about it cause it
just doesn't get a good response.
Blinded.
So when you bought,
I believe you,
you don't seem like a liar by any
stretch of the imagination,
but,
but I have a huge imagination.
I'm sure you do.
I could very easily have been tricking
myself into something.
What do you feel what happens?
Um,
I just bump into that and they just,
if you walk into a room,
I mean it happens maybe once a year.
Yeah.
And you walk into a room,
you walk somewhere or something's going
on and you just feel it and it's a very,
very strong and you,
I just,
I talked to them.
I just say like it mostly hotel rooms.
Let's just say if I'm in a hotel room on
tour and I led their move,
if I don't like it or I'll just say
alone in that room,
I'll be like,
hi,
I'm playing a show at,
so I'm only here for two days,
but I really need to get some sleep.
Um,
you can come to this.
I tell them they can come to the show if
they want.
I'm like,
this is what I do for a living.
And I try to like hear and think what
they do for a living.
I would be psyched if I was a ghost and
I found you.
I'm like,
this chick's cool.
How do you want to scare?
Let her sleep,
man.
Let her sleep.
Fuck down.
I got the pots and pans ready to make a
racket.
Nah Man,
let her sleep.
She's cool.
It's go to the show.
I put 'em on my guest list.
He's got a plus one.
That's nice.
You don't have to reserve a seat for
everywhere.
Obviously you have an active
imagination.
And do you think that maybe your mind
fucking yourself at the time?
Like when you're saying,
well,
you're talking out loud,
are you doing it because it's comforting
because you enjoy it?
Probably,
but,
but if you asked me on a lie detector
test whether I think I really
encountered something,
I'd say yes for sure.
I mean,
there's been enough experiences in my
life that it just seems like just part
of future science.
Hmm.
There's a guy named Rupert Sheldrick,
he's a scientist and he believes that
things have memory.
He thinks that everything has memory
things.
That's why people don't want to live in
haunted houses.
You know?
Don't want to live in a house where
someone died.
He thinks that objects have memory.
They can't express it,
but that they have it.
I agree with that.
It might be.
We like,
we haven't,
I think it's less the object retaining
it.
I mean,
it must be retaining something.
I think it's more our psychic ability to
perceive the past.
Yeah,
that's what I think.
I think it's more like you see the chair
and then you can psychically feel what
happened in that chair.
I'm not really sure how to like,
you're not seeing the chair imbued with
some aura.
You're actually looking into the past.
Yeah,
that's what I think.
Cause I've had dreams that were like
prefiguring
I think you can dream if something's
impactful enough.
I think you can dream.
Okay.
Let's say something really bad happens
to you.
Imagine something horrible.
Okay,
I dunno,
this studio explodes
a couple months.
Maybe before then you might have a
dream.
Well,
let's just say something goes really,
really wrong or bad.
Nothing traumatic.
You might be able to have a dream ahead
of time.
That would be how you would synthesize
that traumatic experience.
Just as if it had happened before and
you were dreaming after the fact before
you've had that happen.
I have,
which I would happen with,
um,
I'm saving that for my book.
Is that okay?
It's okay.
But it was a very powerful,
very,
yeah,
absolutely.
Absolutely.
Absolutely good.
But it was very convincing to me and
hard to explain any other way.
Have you ever had any other sort of
psychic premonition?
Yes.
Do you remember the last big fire we had
in la when it was like encroaching
recently?
Yeah,
that one.
Um,
the night before that fire I was out
walking with my son again,
my son,
he's like all over this podcast.
I don't know why,
cause he barely speaks to me at the
moment and he's like,
yeah,
fine,
good talk to you later.
Um,
and I just felt incredibly uneasy and he
suffered from asthma when he was young
and really badly.
So when it would be when there was a lot
of particulate matter in the air,
or if it was just bad air conditions,
I would tend to be very worried about
him and keep him home or informed the
teachers or whatever it was just he'd
get really bad asthma attacks.
And so I have a predisposition to be on
the alert,
but this is the night before no fire had
started yet.
And I just was very anxious,
very anxious,
and I couldn't settle down.
And I couldn't think for months.
I hadn't been like that.
I mean,
and I said to him,
I'm like,
I don't know what it is,
but I feel kind of unsafe.
If something happens tomorrow,
you have to like,
you have to be my witness that I sensed
something was coming.
Now you probably think I'm this horrible
mother,
I never do this.
It happens like I think I've like said
that to him twice in our entire life and
I forgot about it and the next day I
forgot about it.
I didn't think about it at all until,
you know,
we were socked in in a sort of Brown
muck as we are and like the sun became
the eye of Sauron and ever,
you know,
everyone's like freaking out and we're
looking at all these images and I was so
distracted by all these images that I
completely forgot my sense the night
before and what I think that was until I
remembered it.
Then I called up and I'm like,
ah.
And I think it's more like,
I don't know something's coming,
but I have maybe time,
maybe the envelope with time is a little
bit more mushy than we think.
Maybe we perceive time is very orderly
and very linear,
but maybe it's really not.
And it could be pushing back like the
experience and maybe I had the
experience before I perceive the
experience or I don't know what that is,
but that happens to me a lot.
I've heard people describe,
well,
he likes hearing about it.
By the way,
I never talk about this stuff in my real
life because nobody likes it.
What do you mean it makes people
uncomfortable and they look at you
funny,
so I just never talk about it except for
on
the podcast.
What?
Why would it make them uncomfortable?
It just does.
I'm fascinated by that because I don't
experience it and I'm not,
I've never had a premonition that came
true,
but I do have a really good ability to
know if someone's crazy.
I'm really good at that.
Apparently I'm not.
No,
you're not crazy.
I mean,
I don't know if someone's of crazy
people blind spot.
That's where he could pick out fires in
the distance,
but you can't pick out nuts.
Yeah,
that's it.
I don't have any psychic ability though.
I've just,
I think just,
I don't if you can tell if someone's
crazy or not,
you might have some,
I mean,
you might have some perception and it's
think it's pattern recognition and data
chunking.
Oh,
see,
I've met so many people.
Then when I see things that are off
little things that are off and you
probe,
like you're talking a little,
things are off more and you're like,
you see the looking into the eyes,
you see calculations,
you're like,
okay,
something's going on here.
This is not a,
he's not a normal person.
This is a person putting on a normal
mask.
Like there's something off here.
It just smells,
smells fishy,
you know?
I just think it's that.
I just think that we have them as
guests.
I mean,
are they are sitting across from you?
Oh yeah.
Yeah.
A bat shit crazy.
What are you doing?
I've had people on what I was sure they
were pilled up for sure.
I'm like talking to him like this
motherfucker's adderall to the gills.
Like what does it look like when they're
adderall?
There's have we were talking,
there's just something about the way the
talk to not really cut.
Liz Phair is it?
That's not what it's about.
It's not about me.
It's about the future.
It's about children.
It's about society.
What I'm trying to do is be an
entrepreneur.
I want to build businesses on.
They just start,
they just info wars.
Alex Jones,
we got him high and drunk and he was
talking about on the show.
Is that what goes down here and I like,
oh look at this.
I am in a den of inequity.
Like yes,
we've got some like that's some sudden
that's,
what is that?
Do you want some we could fire
God.
I don't know what will come out of my
mouth.
Good stuff.
Go prescribe.
Huh?
But those are like snoop dogg type
things,
right?
Those are like,
what do they call the joints?
Your backwoods?
No,
they just have a brown paper.
You don't have to have any.
Oh my God.
We're literally getting high right here,
Jamie.
Yes.
We do it all the time.
Seriously?
Yeah.
It was
a podcast.
You can do anything illegal.
Tiny hit.
Take a tiny hit.
There we go.
That's what I'm talking about.
It's definitely not crazy.
It's marijuana.
It's legal.
It's good for you.
It's a staple of civilization.
What will happen?
Nothing.
I don't know.
You'll say cool shit.
Cigarette stuff in it.
No,
that's a cigar leaf though.
no.
It's all just brown paper.
No,
good.
I'm going to try this.
Oh,
settle.
Settle,
settle and see what goes down.
Yeah,
we smoked pot.
It's okay.
I smoke pot.
I'm sure you do.
You just did.
I just did it.
It's proof.
Does evidence people worried?
I mean,
if we had a casual drink,
you know,
if we had it set up a glass of whiskey
or something,
no one would care but marijuana like,
oh my God,
God,
it is weird.
It's like now it's okay.
Like now it's finally,
finally.
It's okay.
Yeah,
fine.
I agree.
30 years of watching people drank really
sucked.
Yeah.
I was never much into alcohol.
No,
I prefer marijuana.
Yeah.
Well you're a sensitive person.
It makes you more sensitive.
Marijuana does.
Sure.
Really?
I think so
for sure.
It makes you more aware,
more,
um,
consider it thinking about more
possibilities.
I mean that's what people call paranoia
really.
It's like a lot of times people live
with blinders on and marijuana just
comes along and goes,
hey,
let's just take those over and uh,
puts a spotlight and like,
look at the back of your brain.
Whoa,
look at this shit you're hiding.
That's exactly right.
It is.
It's like shining a flashlight into your
unconscious.
Like,
did you do what's back there?
I'm like,
oh cool.
Let's get a look at it.
Let's talk to it.
That is what the paranoia is.
I agree with that.
It's like people suddenly are like self
conscious.
They see themselves in a new way and
they're like,
I can't handle this.
Yeah.
That's like 40 years of denial.
Denial.
Yeah.
And,
and all these different mechanisms that
you've kind of like psychological
mechanisms that you've utilized.
Try to hide these thoughts from yourself
or try to skip past them really quickly.
Oh,
I've got that under control and just get
past it and move on to some new thing.
That's a,
that's a common thing.
People love to do it.
Oh,
that's crazy.
I do.
I feel,
I feel like mellow.
Yeah,
it's good.
I like that.
Good.
Still knocked my energy down.
Just a nice nice amount.
Puts you in a condo and I need like a
about 10% energy knockdown,
right?
Maybe 15% yeah,
like a half a hit.
That's what you need.
Like just a little,
just where you're like,
okay.
Yeah,
fine.
Pause,
beat.
Everything's fine.
Fine.
I like that salt lamp.
That's the biggest one I've ever seen.
That's the biggest one would be fine,
but it's um,
it's too big.
They don't look as cool as a small ones
because the small ones,
there's not as much salt to the light
comes through more.
It's one of those things.
It looks cool on paper and then you'd
get it.
I don't think that's cool.
Got The awesome skull there of the long
horn that is an Asian water
buffalo.
Is it friend Adam Green tree shot in
Australia.
That's really cool.
Yeah.
He brought it from Australia for me when
he was a guest on the pocket and just
fly that.
He just put it in a carry on.
No.
Okay.
You imagine weight and it wasn't even
boiled down yet.
It was just the head
blood flies.
Exactly like putting an overhead mic
check it.
It'll fit.
I don't know if you wrapped it up,
he must've because he wouldn't want the
bones to crack or break.
Get knocked around,
but he's being wrapped it up.
Yeah.
That's pretty dope.
He's a wild man.
Bow Hunter and he,
he goes up to the northern area of
Australia,
all the animals.
Essentially.
The large mammals are all invasive
species so they have to hunt them cause
they don't have predators so he goes up
there and shoots water buffalo and the
bone arrow.
That's cool.
I respect that as opposed to other types
of hunting.
I really respect the idea of like mono e
mono,
right.
Going out there and be like,
what don't you respect?
Like just don't go kill them big.
Yeah.
Trophy hunting can fuck off entirely.
It's a weird thing.
It's weird that it's almost like
people hunted entirely for food and then
they got enough food and they go,
I don't want to shoot that thing too.
You know?
It's like they got into shooting things
and it became a thing of not just
shooting stuff for food but shooting
stuff.
Even if you can't justify it.
Like there's some animals,
like,
um,
there's certain haunts that they put on
where they kind of have to control
populations of these things,
like grizzly bears and stuff like that.
When they started encroaching.
Even wolves are certain populations of
wolves they have to control.
And then in the northwest,
but you get to like elephants and
tigers,
lions and like,
what are you doing?
What are they doing?
What are your a man?
Explain that to me.
What is,
what is what,
why does that make you feel important
since you had a gun?
I mean a gun,
you stand back,
you sit in the bushes for,
I dunno,
eight 12 hours and then you pull the
trigger
does,
it doesn't even necessarily make them
feel important.
It's just because they can do it.
And this,
it's exciting.
Like if you were shot a rifle.
Yeah,
yeah.
We go to the rifle range.
It's exciting.
It's fun to just shoot paper,
put paper targets out there and shoot
them.
It's fun.
It feels good.
There's something about like aiming boom
and hitting where you want it to go.
It's exciting.
Yeah.
And so once that,
and there was a real problem is in
Africa it becomes incredibly profitable
for the people that live there.
And then those animals are thriving
because they protect them and have
hunters come in and pay shitloads of
money to hunt them.
So their numbers are really healthy,
which is really crazy.
It's cause like for the longest time,
most of the animals in Africa that are
hunted now in,
in plentiful numbers were on the verge
of extinction.
Let me start out of them.
Still are.
I mean maybe not extinction,
but I don't think that they have an
abundance the big five over there and
yeah,
depends on,
well it depends on where you are,
but Africa obviously it's fucking huge.
Inversely what it looks like when you
took,
but America inside of Africa,
it's like sits over in the SAR up.
It's like it just sits in this tiny
little bitch ass country.
But in Africa there's many animals that
were 20 years ago on the verge of
extinction that are thriving and it's
because of hunting.
Since some of it makes sense in a tiny
little zone,
I mean they're not driving by.
It drove all numbers.
There's the other problem I have with
people calling the,
a lot of the people that hunt over
there,
poachers,
they call it like poachers.
The poachers poaching me.
That's just people who are poor.
That's all it is.
It's just like incredibly poor people
that are trapping these animals.
And some of them,
like if they're shooting rhinos and
stuff like that,
they're now,
they're not doing it because they're
evil.
They're doing it because they're fucking
desperate.
I mean they
are,
that is their game.
I mean it belongs to them.
It's their country.
It's their game if you believe people
and animals.
Yeah,
but,
but I think as as everything,
it's like depending on your perspective,
how much of,
just like we were talking about when you
get high and suddenly your territory
expanse of what your awarenesses,
same difference.
Like this is their country,
this is their,
these are their native population of
animals.
So it's there,
but like taking in a broader scope that
should be utterly protected and
expanding territory rather than like a
little theme park for rich Westerners to
come in and shoot shit.
Yeah.
It's weird.
Have you ever seen a low,
do you know Louis Theroux is,
is there a documentarian from the UK?
He's got a great special that he did or
we went over to one of those wild game
parks is stay with these Weirdos and
these a rich American people that go
over there,
shoot shit and he was over there for
like weeks and finally just drove the
got crazy until the guy was just like
breaking it down to him.
What's really going on.
It was basically just saying in this
crazy accent,
Africa is fucked.
This is what you have to understand.
This African guys explain it to him like
this is the only way these things are
going to survive.
If you think that you're going to remove
these fences and remove the profit,
right.
These people gonna come in and slaughter
these things and they're not going to
think at all about the future.
They're not going to think at all about
preserving the populations or them going
extinct.
I don't think about it at all.
They're just going to wipe them out.
Just like they are doing with Rhino
Horn.
They know rhinos are worth thousands and
thousands of dollars a horn,
so they just shoot those fucking things.
They don't care.
They don't live there.
Their children are starving.
If they find out that they could sell
this Rhino Horn and get x amount $100 or
whatever,
they give them for it,
they're just shoot it.
Like that's their concern is not for
rhinos.
They're concern is for their family or
they're an extreme poverty.
Yeah.
I mean the,
the poverty that they have over their
spooky,
you know,
and in mass mass,
I have a buddy of mine who makes wells
for the pygmies in the Congo,
in the Congo,
and he goes over there all the time.
And uh,
he's actually a fighter.
He's a,
he fights for Bella.
He's one of their top heavyweights.
And he spends like three to months a
year in the Congo,
got caught malaria three times and
animal it's made,
it's justin wren is a beast.
Such a,
such a sweet,
amazing person.
But he goes over there and he says,
you,
you can't believe the kind of poverty he
sleeps in a grass hat grass house when
he's there,
just like they do these,
you know,
they sleep on the F,
they have,
you know,
nope floors.
This is him over there.
That's him with the people.
I mean,
he's a just a leafs that they put on the
roof,
I don't know,
just lease from some local plants that
they use to make their houses,
but he,
you know,
when he tells you what it's like over
there and the extreme poverty,
and most of these people were dying
because of waterborne diseases.
So He created this charity called fight
for the forgotten.
And he goes over there and they build
wells and they've built a ton of wells.
We actually contribute to it.
And we,
um,
there's one of our sponsors,
the cash app.
They,
every time you sign up for it,
they give $5 to these people.
Yeah.
It's amazing.
I mean,
clean water is the most essential.
Yeah.
What a brilliant,
well,
there's a company called water for water
for.org water.
And the number for those people are
also,
uh,
connected with him.
And they just do this everywhere.
They do this all over impoverished
countries.
Go there and just dig wells.
You could change the whole thing because
all these people,
they have distended bellies because
they're filled with parasites and they
have all these waterborne diseases and
they're just,
yeah,
girls don't go to school cause they
spend all day walking to the water
source.
Well nobody goes to school.
There was the pygmies like it's,
they're incredibly uneducated.
I mean it and then unrepresented and not
respected or appreciated and
discriminated against.
And you know,
this is why this guy who's just just big
hulk of a man says,
this is what I'm a concentrate on these,
these small forgotten people.
It's really pretty amazing.
That must be so rewarding just to see
the difference he's making.
Yeah.
I always feel like such a loser whenever
I hang around with it.
I'm worried about what I'm gonna eat for
lunch.
He's quiet of the fucking car and go to
catch malaria for the fourth time.
He said it three times.
That's crazy.
It's fucking not so shit kills people.
Doesn't he just get the shot?
What's the deal?
Can totally stop it.
The problem is when you get it,
once it stays in your system,
he's gotten it again.
When he got a cold like herpes,
like he got it again when he got a cold.
Is that true?
Malaria stays in your cells run to him.
Yeah.
He got it when he wasn't even over
there.
God,
yeah.
And um,
I think you're changing my idea about my
Nile trip that I want to take my pocket
list,
smile trip.
I want to get one of those big house
both things with like,
have you ever seen him?
They're like double deckers and then
they have the top thing and it's just
like a bunch of sort of like games
zones.
Like you just like,
you know,
cool.
Let ons chairs with like covering it.
It's all very open air.
It just feels like you'd be having
cocktails up there at sunset,
walking around,
talking to all your family and friends
that do it.
Like one of those European,
here's what else I'd do.
I'd make sure I had like a security boat
behind me.
Ah,
for the kidnappers and shit.
I'd have my little security about what
that was like a really zippy fast one,
you know.
Good.
You would definitely need that for sure.
Yeah.
A fucked up place though.
Crocodiles alone.
I have a friend who went over there.
Um,
he has a show called the uncharted where
he just travels all over the world and
it goes to these adventures and they
flew him into this,
I think it was the Congo because this
local village was having a problem with
the people.
They're getting eaten by crocodiles and
everyone in the village is like missing
an arm.
They'll bites,
taken out of their legs.
Oh yeah.
These poor people.
I mean they live,
this is the only place where the water
is,
they have to go.
They're leaving create these little
fences where they,
um,
they like try to fence in the area so
the crocodiles can't get to that spot.
They still get in there somehow and fuck
these people up because they've gotten
accustomed to eating them.
Oh No.
Just territorial.
Oh No,
no,
no.
Like a waterhole tension.
Well,
animals are like,
they're opportunists.
And once they decide that your food,
that's when it becomes a real problem.
So there's really like man eating
crocodiles.
Oh yeah.
Well there's,
there's definitely man,
any crocodiles.
Is this Jim shockey?
Yeah,
this is my friend Jim.
And this guy is missing.
Yeah,
it's in Mozambique.
This guy's missing and hand disguise.
Missing his whole arm.
The fence will no wonder they that's in
the gym.
He's a lovely Canadian fellow who
travels everywhere.
So they,
they've,
he's a hunter and they flew him in to
kill these crocodiles for them.
Nice.
It's crazy.
I mean,
look at that fucking thing.
You imagine you're living right there
and there's just God damn dinosaurs
everywhere.
No.
And furthermore,
if you can,
if you can get rid of the,
I don't know,
it must be a learned behavior because
most crocodiles aren't doing that.
It's just that they're near people.
They'll,
they,
their brains are so small and there's
so,
so reptilian that what?
Well,
they're just trying to do is eat.
And if it's a moving,
they're going to try to eat it.
And if it's a person solid,
they're targeting people,
but they found out that they can get
peach row crocodiles.
I don't think they're just going to eat
any old thing.
I think they eat everything they can eat
their giant.
Talking about 1800 pound lizard,
that's been the same.
It's exactly the same form for 60 plus
million years.
You could say the same about sharks and
they don't just go eat you.
They would if they could,
if they just decided to start eating
with the parks and the people.
Yeah.
People eat get eaten by sharks.
No,
they don't.
They don't ever,
no one's ever been eaten by sharks.
Generally they're eating like very
occasionally know Reiki or not eaten by
sharks.
Generally checks don't have a taste for
our blood is what you're saying.
Yeah.
We're not on the menu.
We're not on the menu,
but they will eat us.
They will bite you to get you out of
their zone or they might mistake you and
bite you.
They you cause they think you're
something else but they don't.
You're saying eat,
which means like you sit down and you
finish the meal.
Right.
I think that rarely happens.
Usually they just bite you in half and
just get a follow up.
This tastes like shit.
Am I gonna find a seal zone?
You know?
And like I know there's some
animals that actively target people and
it becomes a giant problem.
Like in India,
in India there's this river,
this place called the cinder bands and
the bull sharks.
No,
no.
These are tigers.
It pulls bull sharks are very aggressive
and they do kill people,
but these aren't tiger sharks there.
Tigers,
just the cat.
They kill a lot of people.
Yeah.
The shit out of you.
No.
Sit down and like put the Napkin in
their color and get like there.
Yeah.
Well the actively hunt people in this
one place and they've been doing it for
hundreds of years.
They've,
they said over the last 200 years,
300,000 people have been killed by
tigers in the cinder bands.
Yup.
Over the last 200 years,
300,000 people who have been killed by
tigers.
I don't know what to do with that
number.
It's implausible is insane.
It's just so common.
First of all,
India has a billion people,
right?
And a lot of them are really poor and
they live in by these rivers and these
cats are everywhere and it's tall grass.
You've ever seen that video of the cat,
that giant tiger leaping up and
attacking the guy when he's on an
elephant?
No.
This is shows.
Yeah,
we'll shows you pull it up to me.
It shows you how crazy India is.
This guy's on top of an elephant and
he's walking this elephant through this
grass and this tiger runs through the
grass and leaps up in the air and fucks
my boys on this elephant.
I shouldn't laugh,
but it's kind of funny.
It's like,
it's kind of funny.
What a hell of a tiger
there.
They're insane.
I mean,
if a tiger was in a movie as a monster,
it'd be what?
We want to scare his monsters ever this
on youtube.
Oh yeah.
We can't play it on youtube,
but just everyone knows what it is.
Yeah,
don't pull it down because somebody owns
this.
They have a copyright.
So here's the guy.
So he's on top of this elephant.
Now look at the grass and they spot it.
And then the thing,
yeah.
Wow,
whoa.
Yep.
It is on.
Oh my God jumps
and it's going after him.
It knows that he's up there.
Look at it.
It's like,
bitch.
Well,
if I were the elephant,
I just messed that tiger up.
Tore the guy's arm apart.
The elephant didn't really give a fuck.
It's just hanging out.
I looked the elephants like,
whatever,
bitch.
Tigers can't kill me.
Even outside,
just stomp on it.
Pretty sure tigers don't kill elephants,
but lions do.
And when lions do,
they're really hungry and they get a
bunch of them and they gang up
upon an elephant.
Okay.
Don't talk about,
because you're going to talk about the
baby elephants that get ganged up on
first.
Oh,
not even necessarily babies.
They'll take out a real elephant.
Well,
not if it's with the herd.
What is this?
Trying to save a goat woman fights off
tiger with a stick.
Let the goat girl cry slowly.
It's a fucking girl.
The kangaroo punching ones.
Those.
That's my name.
That dude,
I want to marry that dude.
You know,
it's like trying to figure it out.
Awesome.
Right?
People were mad at that guy.
He's so cute.
But if you're an animal lover,
Kangaroos fucking up his dog.
Kangaroos,
those male kangaroos fight all the time.
They're always like punching.
That was just like a really fun,
this is the guy.
He's going to get his dog.
So I would do the same thing cause it's
got the dog because this guy is so
awesome,
so weird.
They don't even seem real.
They seem to human.
Yeah,
look at that.
Here we go.
Thinking about it.
Bam.
It's like,
yeah bitch.
I just love the kangaroo does not know
what to do.
He's like,
am I supposed to fight you?
He's so cute.
I was like fuck this.
What a weird animal.
But it bounces off like that when two
legs guy though,
right?
Oh yeah,
for sure.
And also that he didn't follow up.
What do you think they were?
What was it doing like just fighting it
or playing with a dog was barking.
The kangaroo decided to grab a hold of
dog and get him in a headlock and that's
what they do.
Which is
generally giving you time to react a
different way.
That's giving you a moment to not
escalate.
Yes,
sure.
If you see the beginning of the video,
he's running around this kangaroo,
he thinks he's hunting.
He thinks he's like alerting his company
in the car to target.
Right.
If you don't even seem like a real
animal,
they seem like something from an avatar
movie.
Right.
You want to cuddle with them all.
When I see like all I want is to take
them all home and just cuddle with them.
Guy Punched him right in the face too
early.
You know that for on their bellies.
Really like,
dude,
that's a duty I don't see.
I don't see,
he's not as big as,
I think that's a woman.
It might be because she's not very big.
That also makes sense to that.
That's what that pouches,
where the tummy,
what's,
I think there's a little thing right
there.
It says something,
that little thing hanging down there
like a penis.
Now the tails back here.
No,
that can't be the penis.
Huge Penis.
Come on.
Where's the balls bouncing around?
There it is.
Maybe that's just like the curtain for
the vast,
very developed kangaroo.
He's not going to win many fights.
He's sort of a Beta there,
right?
There's some giant Kangaroos.
Those big scary one.
So get this one knocking on the door.
Hey Man.
Hey Man,
look at the clause and those funds.
That's what I'm saying.
When you put the dog in the headlock,
he could easily have taken care of that
dog.
But he didn't.
He like,
he kept the head.
He was like,
I'm shutting this down.
I really think we're mis-gendering.
I think we're mis-gendering that
kangaroo.
Like it's a girl.
It looks like a dude.
See Look,
the difference you see his car,
maybe kangaroo chases people cause
that's muscles.
Is it really chasing people?
Yeah,
cause it has muscles.
Maybe it's a female.
That guts does a lot of crossfit.
The secret life of golfers.
Like there's,
there's crocodiles on the golf courses,
there's Kangaroos.
What else is like going on for those
guys?
Lightning.
Oh yeah.
Golfers die.
Golfers.
They're holding onto a piece of metal.
Yeah.
How many golfers die every year from
lightening strikes?
I say happened to somebody I know or my
parents knew I was there when it
happened.
He died and there was like a,
they were all in the clubhouse and he
must have stepped outside cause he
thought nothing would have happened.
And Yeah,
lightning struck.
Why used to hear about that all the
time,
right?
Like people would have to come home.
And how many people do you think Liz
phair take?
Guess what?
Every year.
Number every year.
Well,
I'm going to go with strikes over
deaths.
I wasn't going to go straight.
I'm going to say strikes.
I'm going to say there's about
struck by lightning.
At least a couple hundred,
couple hundred regular golfers.
Just Golf.
Just golfers.
Ooh.
Ooh,
I'm going to go with worldwide Knight's
states.
Just United States.
It seems unfair.
Okay.
Worldwide.
I'm going to go with
25 I like it.
I was gonna,
I was gonna say 23 worldwide.
I say three strikes.
These are not jeff average.
51 annual lightning strike fatalities
over the last 20 years on your estimate.
And we worry about that.
And the second visit is one a year,
but how many of those guys are golfers?
That's what I typed in action that are
assholes with a kite with a key hanging
off of it.
I type thing.
How many golfers die each year from
lightening,
but how many people,
how many people are cooking cello?
Right?
You go 5% of the annual ones happened on
golf courses.
So 5% of equity one is like estimated 10
to two and a half.
Something like that.
Not a lot.
Yeah.
I said three.
He missed how bad I am at math.
One is
10 there's no way you're as bad as me.
That's pretty bad.
I'm bad.
I'm very bad.
I think that's inherited.
Two.
My kids suck at math too.
I figure if you don't have to like if
you can look it up easily like names,
dates,
math.
Yeah.
I don't think you have to remember.
Well that's what I'm saying to my kids.
I'm like,
look,
you see the phone calculator,
we'll learn how to do that.
I'm delegating,
delegating that to Google.
Let Google figure it out.
Trusting Google,
trust in your overlords.
Lifting.
I'm going to do like the big picture,
you know,
trust in your overlord.
All these little Gizmos.
What is that is a clock made by tgt
studios.
It's a guy who's a,
he's an artist and he makes these things
all lot of it's all handmade out of
wood,
walnut and he gets these Russian.
What are those things called?
Those things that are inside of it.
[inaudible]
Nixey tube and that's how he gets it to
read the numbers and shit.
What does it mean?
Is it just one 47 it's the time.
One 47 and 46 seconds.
He's bad ass.
He does a lot of really cool shit.
He's a craftsman.
He does a lot of like really fascinating
stuff.
You got his instagram page,
tgt studios.
Do you ever check Daily Mail for like
the hideous side of life?
I checked the Internet for the hideous
side of life.
What do you,
what are you checking?
I do check Daily Mail.
It's like my horrible and I disguise
myself every time I do.
There's a dude's website.
Pretty Dope,
right?
Yeah,
it is really cool.
it makes cool stuff.
So what do you like,
what are you looking for?
I really just want the gossip.
I'm just there to find out.
It's like going to the,
you know the well in the village though.
I want to know what's going on with
that,
exactly what it is.
But then they always sneak in something
like utterly devastatingly just shocking
and awful.
Like,
you know,
they would,
they'd have Kim Kardashians next to like
the isis beheadings and it would be like
side by side so you couldn't miss it.
And I know that that's part of like your
friend,
the hunter,
the adrenaline rush.
I know that's part of why I go there
because it might,
my sister might be shocked a little bit.
Yeah.
But it's,
it's a revolting impulse.
Like that's the worst of me
you get.
It's like a big tub of ice cream that's
in your fridge every day and you know
you should need it and you do what?
You just make your underwear
and you're like,
what the fuck is wrong with me?
Why did I do every time I watch one of
those videos after it's over,
I'm like,
why the fuck did I watch that?
Yeah.
Do you think that stuff like adds up in
your brain?
Like how much of our stress and
unhappiness and all that kind of stuff
that culturally everybody feels is
because you expose yourself to things
that you just shouldn't know about?
I think for sure,
for sure it has an effect.
It's a matter of a,
does it have an effect as in as far as
raising awareness of consequences of
devious actions or does it have an
effect in that you're always worried
about it and so it sort of manifests
itself more often because it's
constantly in your head.
The ladder probably makes sense.
And then we needed a cup of coffee,
a drink and a joint.
Yeah.
Just to just try to unwind and find a
group of people that you could hang out
with the trust that are cool to protect
you from all those fuckers coming over
the fence.
Right.
I mean this one was worried.
Oh,
circle to everybody's worried this would
worry about Russia.
Right?
Everyone's worried about Russia.
I'm not worried,
I'm pissed.
Do you see the thing that there are
parking submarines over to the power
line over the Internet lines?
I was wondering about that.
What?
I don't know.
Like probably to let us know he full
color we could could line with no
problem if that happened.
How fast do you think it would take
before we got something back up again?
Or how and how fast crazy that there's a
line that goes across the fucking ocean
and that's how the Internet,
yeah.
Yes.
There are times when I will sit and
dream about those lines and I'll just
sit there thinking,
I'll see this sort of greenish merck and
then I'll see you hear the silence in
that clicking sound that you're under,
you know with all the fishes eating
stuff that like
what do I like clicking stuff and I'll
picture these lonely ass cables just
draped down the side of a cliff,
like in the great abyss and like how
just picture their loneliness for
awhile.
Wow.
Yeah.
That's intense.
Whoa,
they're everywhere.
Yeah.
You imagine if aliens came here and saw
that,
they'd be like,
what in the fuck are these crazy
assholes wires?
I asked my son what he thinks we're
going to look back on in the future and
think was like the craziest thing we
lived with and he said wires and I
thought it was kind of brilliant.
That's what a kid would say,
right?
That lives the world today.
That is brilliant
wires.
I could just play live and move anywhere
around on the stage.
I didn't have to stand in front of me.
The fact that we stand in front of a
mic.
I know there's a great tradition and
it's really cool and rock and roll,
but I personally feel very hemmed in by
this Mike,
Stan,
I have to stand up straight.
Bobbi Brown.
I did and I was like,
all my friends just took me aside and
they were like,
no,
can't do it.
It works for Anthony Robbins.
He does it.
He does it right.
It doesn't need go.
Bobby Brown,
whenever it's anybody wears those.
It's Bobby Brown period.
He did it for my prerogative,
but that's it for the rest of everyone's
life.
That's a Bobby Brown,
Bobby Brown.
I know a comic who does that really does
is act with,
I'd fucking don't get it.
There's Anthony Robbins look at up big
beautiful son of a bitch.
At one point I bought the box set.
You know,
at one point I was like trying in my car
to listen to my positivity.
He's got some very good points.
He says some things that really can
work,
but you know,
it's like,
here's the thing,
Anthony Robbins is like any delicious
meal.
You do not want to eat it all fucking
day,
every day.
And if you hear too much Anthony
Robbins,
he's like,
okay,
he fucking enough.
I get it.
Be Positive.
Put out the energy.
We're going to walk on coals.
It's weird too.
Why is he wet?
He does do that.
But here's what's interesting about
today,
cause he's fucking jacked and he's just
running and sweating up a storm.
Getting these people pumped.
Maybe it's raining out.
I'd be ready.
Yeah,
it could be.
Um,
well they do this fire walk thing,
which is essentially,
here's the thing,
Coles.
Yeah,
go for it.
With my Bobbi Brown Brown,
if you have one of those,
you can be totally wireless,
right?
Just hook it up into a backpack.
Wireless action with him.
A little free.
Free Fair.
Well,
okay.
She's tired.
Yeah.
That should be a a t shirt that just
says free fair.
And it's just the Bobbi Brown thing,
like a silhouette of your head with just
the dark Bobbi Brown thing over your
face.
Someone's going to make it by the end of
this podcast.
So many.
We'll have that and we're going to put
it up on instagram.
Bobbi Brown.
I want a parabolic parachute thing over
my whole stage.
Anywhere I go.
Don't they have that for sports now they
have this like parabolic microphone
thing where I think and like zoom in on
the coach talking or zoom in on it got
this thing where like it's very
directional,
right?
Like a laser of a microphone so it can
be up in the ceiling of the arena and
then they just pointed at somebody and
it can go right in and hear that
conversation.
A shit.
Right.
I don't even using it yet.
Know that they can listen to what you
say in a room by monitoring the window
and the vibrations of normal human
conversation has enough of an effect on
the window that they can translate that
in December
beach.
That's insane.
Whoa.
They know the noises you're making based
on the effect it has on a window in a
room.
You don't even have to be screaming
just talking.
That's crazy.
No,
that's real.
Well don't you kind of just assume that
we're being listened to all the time now
after Edward Snowden and all that stuff
after you know,
the,
the releases of,
I feel like I've got at least two fans
listening in to me at all times.
And your house just,
and like the NSA,
like to Liz Phair but I'm sure there's
more.
Yeah,
they probably poured like I'm going to
find a terrorist.
But
yeah,
it's probably a lot of actually thought
about that the other day cause I screwed
up my knees and I've been doing this
thing where like put my elbows into my
legs is I'm sitting watching tv or
something.
Kind of give myself a massage.
But if you were listing through the
audio of my phone or anything,
you just think I was constantly
mastered.
This is kind of like rubbing motion on
that.
They're like,
she's never getting off.
She keeps stopping.
What's the
blockage?
She's frantic.
Like what?
What are those like the primates that
are constantly,
yeah.
Bonobos.
Vanilla.
Yeah.
I mean we're going to get to a point
where everybody can listen in on
everybody.
That's what I think.
I think we're only a couple of decades
away from that.
I think right now it's like content or
a,
you know,
a service providers have the possibility
of tapping into you.
Maybe you know all these different
government groups knows how to tap into
your phones and tap into your TV and tap
it in the camera that's on your laptop.
But I think it's going to come a matter
of time.
But that's the intrusion of privacy is
going to be the bottleneck to future
technology.
And we're going to get to some virtual
reality environment where it is so tight
tonically and so incredibly realistic
that whatever the fuck happens in the
regular world is going to lose its
significance.
It's going to slowly lose significance
to the point where we're going to accept
that.
One of the ways to overcome some of
these technological hurdles as to
completely dissolve all boundaries
between all people and information.
Meaning you're going to be able to look
at anybody doing anything anytime and
they're gonna be able to look at you and
that's going to be the new reality of
human beings.
And this will be after we've accepted
virtual reality,
so once we accept virtual reality,
regular life is going to be so mundane
because you're going to be able to
create artificial environments like
Avatar world,
like you're flying through 2001 a space
odyssey.
You're hanging out with the champs,
you're going to have haptic suits on,
they give you feedback.
It's going to be tied into your central
nervous system.
It's going to recreate smells and feels
and that's all going to happen.
It's not a matter of whether it's going
to happen,
it's a matter of when is it going to
happen.
I think when that does happen,
the big bottleneck is going to be
privacy and I think people are going to,
just like they're doing now with
constantly putting up things on social
media,
constantly showing pictures of their
kids and constantly giving updates on
everywhere you go and tagging all these
things at Geo tags.
I think that in the future we're going
to just accept that no one has any
privacy and kids today are more likely
to accept it than we were and our kids
are going to be more likely to accept it
then their kids and it's going to keep
going on and on and on and three,
four generations.
It's going to be life.
Life is going to be no privacy.
Like if we were all living in like a big
brother Type House is fucking no
privacy,
right?
There's cameras everywhere.
There's people willingly do it.
How long before everybody willingly does
it?
It's a matter of time.
Right now it's a,
it sounds impossible because we grew up
valuing privacy.
I need my alone time.
I don't want anybody paying attention to
what I'm doing,
but once meet human beings are so
incredibly malleable that once life
changes around us and we know for a fact
this is an extra ball,
this is not going back and lets
yellowstone blows.
We get hit by an asteroid.
This is life now we're just gonna accept
it.
It's going to go into the next thing and
you're going to deal with people looking
at you naked all the time,
lol.
Because you don't care because you're in
the Avatar dimension.
Riding a fucking dragon over a volcano
and you going to be living in a world
that's so much more fantastic in the
real world that someone looking at your
asshole and the real world,
you're like,
go ahead,
look,
who cares.
You're basically saying that we're
putting ourselves in those little pods
and the Matrix.
Yes.
You're saying that we're willingly
climbing in eventually to these little
pods of Google and,
and,
and powering the whole machine age.
Yeah.
Cause we're just going to plug in.
I think we're going to be symbiotic.
I think we're going to become part
machine.
I think it's inevitable.
Colony.
Yeah.
You know where it kind of like an ant
collector.
One organism with many,
many parts.
Yeah.
I think it's a matter of time.
That is that okay.
You don't have to,
you're alive right now.
You're alive.
You're alive and a beautiful time.
And the transition between when you were
young and there was no
internet to now you've been an adult
where there's internet.
This is the most amazing time ever.
We're lucky.
We're the most lucky cause we've
experienced both.
We've experienced,
I mean when I was a kid we didn't have
fucking answering machines.
No,
I know.
Right.
You just called and hope they were home.
Yeah.
And that they weren't home.
You never found them.
You,
you open that door to your house,
you were a ghost.
You just guide bid that a trust.
You,
you were where you said at work you just
went places,
you do whatever you want,
you know,
and that's the last wild ones.
That's what we are.
We are the last,
we're the last of the disconnected,
you know,
we were disconnected and then we became
connected in the 1990s though.
That's a totally new experience for
human beings.
And we experienced both parts.
We were the last humans to experience no
internet internet.
No one else will ever experience that.
The only way they'll experience that is
if they don't have internet.
But the world has internet.
You know what?
I want to get back to what you said.
How long is the electricity down?
If we're attacked on the infrastructure?
That's what I want to know what we were
talking about the internet,
but some of the Internet.
The same thing.
Yeah.
Look,
that's another,
that's an issue too.
Oh,
that's all.
They're going to blow his internet,
but it would be like the saddest attack.
Wow.
EMP can take us out to,
which suggests a scary and probably
easier to accomplish.
That's what I want to know about,
like how long is the recovery time?
Because
I do feel like Putin sitting back,
they're like,
well,
I think what they're really worried
about other than Putin is solar flares.
They think solar fairs have the real
potential to take out the entire power
grid.
That's,
that's entirely possible and big.
We know.
Oh,
that too.
Yeah.
Yeah,
for sure.
That's only one thing.
Yellowstones the big one.
Oh,
that was like a stoner moment.
We all just stopped.
They know about the,
the Caldera volcano in yellowstone,
you know?
Yeah.
That's the big one.
I do.
I'm not,
everybody should be free.
I was worried about that,
although I know what the bulging,
hmm.
Yeah.
I think the northwest part is bulging or
say,
well,
it's just constantly have an earthquake.
They've got thousands of earthquakes
every year for like the last five or six
years.
Thousands and thousands in a month.
So Times that to me is not worth
worrying about because there's nothing
we can do that is like that.
You might as well just the,
what I said they want it.
They want to dig a hole.
No,
they want to drill a hole and let some
of the gas out.
Well,
wow.
I applaud their like,
you know,
well,
yeah.
Didn't want to lance a zit or some of
the lava out.
What's crazy?
Is it that that's happened to human
civilization like many times over the
course of history at giant volcanoes
blown up and killed everybody?
Yeah.
A bunch of that shit happened to,
yeah.
I'll,
I'll be loving life because I'm small.
I think only the small things survive,
right.
I Dunno.
They said about the,
um,
the,
what hit the Yucatan is that we used to
be like a mole.
Like human beings.
They di if you trace the evolution of
the human being,
if you believe in that nonsense today,
if you go all the way back,
we were like a mole.
We're some kind of a mold that was the
only survivor.
Yeah.
Literally 65 million years ago.
Human beings are our farthest mammal
ancestor is some sort of a mole that
survived the big hit.
Yeah.
Like shrewish Mulligan thing.
And cause all the upper predators get
wiped out so then they can thrive and
they live in a ground so that these
things can live underground and of what
our future would be like underground.
Everyone,
thanks for joining Mars.
But I think we're just going to go
underground.
We are going to go to Mars too though.
Some idiots support Fox are going to be
no thank you.
No thank you cass.
Why do people want to do that?
Because we can because it's one of those
go sit and like badlands.
That's what I'm saying.
You're done.
And you can come back and have pie.
Yeah.
It's dumb.
And then you have to bring water or have
to go get it and melt it down with,
but you're there.
Okay.
You're on Mars.
Let's just say we're on Mars.
What do we do?
We're just terrify me.
Cry.
Stop working.
Rock.
Yeah.
Do I mean I just don't see the life
there.
Well,
I think people want to be pioneers and I
think it's entirely possible that you're
going to wind up going with some really
crazy people too.
Yeah,
right.
Yeah.
He wants to be a pioneer.
That isolated.
Yeah.
Crazy pants.
Right?
See if I know a lady who lives in the
Arctic Circle.
She lives like two more hundred miles
above the arctic circle.
She's on that shield life below zero.
You ever see that show?
But she can come out when she wants.
She can come back.
She flies back.
She ain't,
she was in the studio,
not this one,
the old one,
but she was sitting right where you're
sitting like,
you know she's a normal person.
I can't even take a cruise.
No,
no,
but you're going to cruise in the Congo.
That's a river,
but I can't take a cruise boat because I
can't be isolated in the middle of the
ocean with people I don't think are
really on the ball.
Like I can't do it.
I think that's where like the next
plague starts I think does happen
sometimes.
Yeah,
they get the norovirus or whatever on a
cruise ship.
I want,
if someone was just really in a chuck
and people over the side,
like that's your move.
You just take a crew of people that
survive that.
I like the stories of the people that
fall off the cruise ship and they get
bound.
Who the fuck finds him there in a
shipping lane?
They get found.
Really?
I've loved those stories.
I've never heard those doors.
I always thought your fuck you imagine,
could you,
there's almost nothing that can fuck you
worse than to fall off a cruise ship.
But these people,
they,
they survive it.
You have to think of how long can you
swim,
right?
I mean it's like 13 hours or I dunno,
how long can you tread water?
Well,
you can tread water longer than that.
Oh no,
sure.
You can.
I sink like a rock.
You'll be hallucinating.
Right.
But you still be treading water.
You just be your tissue
tearing apart.
What I heard one guy talk about was how
he saw,
like he had the illusion of seeing boats
come by and talk to him and he like
talked to people that were saying just
hang on,
hang on longer.
It was all imaginary.
Like none of it was real.
But he was having like a full sort of
trippy virtual reality experience with
his hallucinations that kept him alive
longer.
They were like his subconscious,
but they would come in his mind in
vessels and like stop and talk to him,
throw him something.
Wow.
Motivate him.
That's crazy.
I guess you could get that if you go
into one of those,
um,
sensory deprivation tanks or something
that,
oh,
you do?
I want to run over here.
Shut up.
Fuck you.
Oh Wow.
Yeah.
Well,
do you do that regularly?
Yeah.
Do you have a loose nations?
Yeah,
definitely.
Tell me.
Um,
the,
the most extreme one.
I was in a jungle and um,
there was some people that were native
to this place.
They were dressed in western clothes
though,
like t shirts and shorts,
but they were barefoot,
which is often the case though
unfortunately a lot of people that live
in these indigenous villages,
they were like under armour shirts and
shit that they,
someone gets them somehow it gets down
to them.
Missionaries maybe sometimes bring them.
Um,
but they were speaking in a language
that I understood,
but it was an English and I don't speak
anything other than English.
And when they were talking,
I was listening to them,
I was amongst them and I was listening
to them and they were speaking of is
very different language.
And then I realized like,
Holy Shit,
I can understand their language,
but I realized that in English.
And then Poof,
I popped out of the,
the spell like my freaking out about it
brought me,
it was all like,
don't know.
No,
don't go away.
Don't go away.
Ah,
fuck.
It's like,
it was so extreme.
It was so I could smell the,
the rain,
I could feel the moisture in the air.
I could see the leaves all around me.
I could hear the sounds of the forest
and these people in the rain forest just
hanging out talking to this.
It was totally uneventful.
Nothing was happening.
But they were talking in this language
that I absolutely knew what they were
saying.
They were going back and forth and
communicating and I was following the
conversation in their language,
thinking in their language and then I
realized it and I woke up.
How do you interpret,
I think first of all,
I was tripping balls,
right?
There's that,
there's been in that tank on what?
Uh,
I think it was edible pot.
I've done a bunch of different things in
the tank,
but mostly it's edible pot.
Pot Edibles has a distinctly
hallucinatory effect at high doses,
especially when you close your eyes and
you're laying back.
And just like,
just,
just letting visuals place.
Um,
also I think it's entirely possible that
we have genetic memory and I think it's
entirely possible that like there's
certain things that people pass down to
their children.
Like there are certain traits that my
kids have that are watching them.
And I go,
okay,
how do you,
why are you so into this?
Are you so into this because you just
happen to be into this?
Are you into this because you cause I'm
into this and somehow or another gotten
in my jeans and passed on to your little
tiny body and now you're developing with
this like hunger for certain certain
types of activities.
Because I see it literally
will little note,
we don't know what's transferred.
We don't know how much of like what
links people have certain instincts,
right?
People are afraid of,
spiders are afraid of snakes.
Why?
Why is that?
It's probably some memory.
Probably somewhere along the line some
memory got transferred into your DNA.
Well the question is like how much gets
in there until I hope my nine year old
daughter,
I thought probably very little.
I was probably,
it's just like physical traits and
that's it.
But her mind is so much like my mind,
like,
and especially her obsession with
things.
I've never seen a little kid so obsessed
with things like this is me in a nine
year old girl's body.
Like this is fucking crazy.
And talking to people that have musical
talent or people that have artistic
talent and their children seem to have
an aptitude for this,
like an an unusual attitude almost as if
they're trying to remember it rather
than learn it.
Ooh,
I like what you just said.
I like that area.
I think there's something that gets
trend.
I don't,
I don't know how much of it is readable
data,
but I think there's so much information
that gets through yourselves and then I
think the child is faced with their own
data,
right?
Their own life experiences,
their own genetics,
they're on hormones and all these
different things that are happening
around them.
But I think underneath all of that,
it's entirely possible.
There remains some very,
very distant memories,
which is why people survived as long as
they did because you could transfer some
knowledge until the kids,
I think it's probably less today than
before because the world's so safe.
Everything's nerved.
You don't have to worry about getting
eaten by leopards.
Like it's a,
it's a totally different environment.
We live in it so less of it gets in
there.
But I think there's probably still
somewhere in the operating system.
If you went into dos and started
sneaking around,
you'd find some weird code from like
different languages that you spoke
10,000 years ago or you know,
who knows whatever life experience.
Like why are kids scared of monsters?
Those are another thing that they were
talking about once in one of these
things.
Like they're scared of monsters because
monsters used to be a real thing that
you had to worry about it cause they ate
people like cats,
like leopards and jaguars and shit.
Like that was a real problem.
So little kids,
they're not scared of bullets or you
know,
they're scared of fucking monsters.
That's what every little kid scared of
the dark.
And monsters because that's in our
genetic memory.
Probably some leftover shit for when we
got eaten a lot in trees.
Trees.
Right.
So falling and pronation.
Yeah,
both.
So is that what you think happened?
Like that you kind of access to memory
because I was going more with like the
um,
what do you call it?
Collective unconscious.
Like you were seeing a present day thing
in another part of the war all I doubt
it.
No,
you're going back in your,
I think it was his imagination more than
anything,
honestly find to be really honest.
I think it was imagination.
I think I just have a very vivid
imagination and it's particularly when I
was lit on some,
okay,
I've read a study where,
um,
if something really traumatic happens to
the parents,
and I don't know if this is animals or
whatever,
even if the baby animal is born after
this thing is over,
this traumatic event,
they'll have a fear of that thing is
that was very poorly articulated,
I think the pots like gone through me.
No,
no,
no.
I'm just like sort of,
I think I know what you're talking
about.
There was a study that they did with
mice and what they do with mice as they
sprayed a citrus and aroma inside the
cage.
And then the electrocuted the feed of
the mice,
their children when they smelled this is
children that had not had been
electrocuted when they smelled that
citrus aroma,
they had a heightened panic state.
Yeah,
yeah.
That's what it is.
Yeah.
But that's,
is that how they figured that out?
Because that seems like I can explain
that with normal science.
That's easy.
Right.
Um,
cause they'll have the sense,
well no,
never.
They never experienced the electrocution
thank before on the smell.
Right.
But the smell never gave them a
heightened sense of awareness in mice
that weren't fetus would be shocked.
Oh,
you're saying they weren't pregnant?
No,
no,
they weren't pregnant.
Oh,
this is before their pregnancy,
if not even there.
Right.
Exactly.
Okay.
So what explains that genetic memory?
It's a,
it's a piece of evidence appointed
genetic memory,
but it's one of those things.
It's like if you don't understand,
go back to dos are c plus or something
like that.
Some computer code.
I don't understand it.
If I read it,
it's just jibberish to me or like those
quantum physics guys and write all that
stuff does just gibberish.
So we might be just getting that gerrish
going and what is,
what's going on here?
No one knows,
right?
We don't know.
One day maybe we'll be able to read that
jibberish but right now we know there's
something getting passed down from these
mice,
so if the parent gets shocked because
they smell that thing and then the kids
who have nothing to do with it,
they get shocked or they a smell it and
they think they're going to get shocked.
Something's being transferred to that.
That's crazy.
That means that we have components of
our parents.
Like right now we're reacting to stuff
in our everyday life.
Our fears,
our worries,
our neuroses.
Yeah.
Possibly things that our parents
experienced.
Okay.
It's entirely possible that you didn't,
neuroses of your parents is somehow or
another transferred into your body,
whether or not you accept them as your
own.
Because I'm adopted.
That means I have two sets of neuroses
going at once and wonder and one
doubling down on,
I wonder how much your adoptive parents
gave you sticks.
What does this,
who does?
Another study's authors,
Wa,
uh,
was an early researcher of trauma,
trauma and heritability.
Her research on Holocaust survivors
found that epigenetic changes,
not the genes themselves,
but how they are turned on and off by
other molecules could be passed down to
survivors,
children and change their stress
hormones.
Wow.
There's a bit,
what does that,
how does that express itself though?
Not genes themselves,
but how they are turned on and off,
but by other molecules could be passed
down.
So they're going to be heightened,
they're going to have a heightened
sensitivity to threat.
Probably.
Probably they're going to have like a
quicker response neurologically.
Will they say that about,
um,
children that are in the womb when their
mother is under extreme stress or
violence?
They can sense that.
Yeah,
for sure.
Yeah.
But what freaks me out is that the,
it's not even like a fetal baby that's
reacting this.
Yeah.
Like complete genetic material
transference.
Yeah.
Who knows?
I don't think we know enough future
science.
Yeah.
That's what you're into.
I'm weighing the future science.
I wish we lived in the future.
So that's where ghosts fit in.
I just go,
I mean,
future science,
I think I just think time.
I think time is a,
an illusion.
I think that I'm more,
did you ever see interstellar?
Yes.
I'm more in that zone.
Hmm.
That's that smacked of good science to
me.
I was like,
yes.
So when you say time's an illusion,
you mean like the watch is real?
Like if it says four 30 that's when the
movie starts,
right?
That's all real.
No,
that's just coordination.
That's it's,
it's within our species.
We're coordinating together.
We're working as an ant colony.
We're sending signals,
which happened to be time signals.
We're using math to coordinate,
but if you go underwater and hold your
breath for five minutes,
that's real five minutes.
No,
that's just when you run out of oxygen.
So that five minutes,
that is the counting of that time
doesn't mean anything.
Doesn't mean anything.
No,
it doesn't mean anything.
But if someone's five minutes late,
you're like,
bitch,
you're five minutes late.
Right.
Well I'm never mad about that because
I'm always late,
so,
oh,
okay.
Hmm.
That's interesting.
Um,
well the only time supposedly is now and
everything else is just are pathetic
attempts at measuring it and trying to,
that's just coordination on like,
you know,
people like that's all we're doing.
Like how old are you?
Um,
you know,
and then that just means how crispy you
are from going around the sun.
That's not like really anything
accessory.
Yeah.
You're like,
sorry.
Right,
right.
Skin.
Cracklin you know,
like it's just kind of that and to me
like time,
it's just,
it's just space.
It's like how far are you away from this
gravitational pull?
I think gravity is way more interesting.
I think time is just us coordinating
with math.
Well,
we definitely are,
but it's also like when Sun's coming up,
like check your watch,
six 15 sun's coming up.
That's a real thing.
We're just clocking a spin of an earth.
Yeah.
It's the same thing with the lungs under
water.
The earth spins.
I agree with you.
Yeah.
Disagree with you at the same time.
Yeah,
that's fine.
I think you're right.
But I also think the fucking movie
starts at four 30.
That's another human putting on a movie.
It's true.
You're just coordinating with,
give me an example of time that is a
manifest thing outside of human
coordination.
Um,
well,
you could the oldest,
I don't mean like things happening,
right?
I mean time,
just time itself.
Is that helpful in any way?
Other than for us?
I don't think it exists in the universe
really.
Well,
if the universe had a big bang and that
was a point,
I don't
living room.
Sorry.
What do you think?
I think we're looking at,
okay.
Black holes.
Say there's a train,
right?
We're at a where to depot.
Okay.
I love that word.
Train depot.
Depot.
Like home depot or a train depot.
Okay.
And there's like a giant but of a train.
Right?
Huge.
I Dunno.
20 feet tall,
18 feet wide,
filled with that legs.
That shame,
that feeling of like,
oh my God,
there's great mechanical power and then
it leaves the depo,
but you're still there.
You didn't get on it.
Right.
And it,
it just travels in the distance into a
Tinier and Tinier,
Tinier,
tinier speck until it's just a little
point until you can't see it anymore.
Did the train shrink?
No.
Okay.
So when you see all this matter going
into a black hole,
is it really hitting a singularity or we
really condensing matter to that extent?
Or is it just condensing to a certain
extent and traveling in the distance?
Is it going somewhere?
And that's why we perceive it as gone.
It's basically to run this by an
astrophysicist and then they break out
the worm hall.
But that's not the same thing.
That's not what I'm saying.
Like,
and I think the big bangs or the other
end of that process,
the under end of the process of coming
out,
that's a,
that's a real,
uh,
thought.
They think that,
well,
every galaxy has a super massive black
hole black hole that's in the center of
it.
One half of 1% of the mass,
the entire galaxy.
So the larger the galaxy,
the largest supermassive black hole,
the prevailing theory is that,
or one of the prevailing theories I
should say inside every black hole may
be another universe.
It's entirely possible that there's
another universe of hundreds of billions
of galaxies each with supermassive black
holes in the center of them,
and he'd go through that one you go
into,
it's fractal and it just goes on forever
and ever and ever.
That's entirely,
that's my philosophy.
And I think the whole Universe is
spinning.
I think the whole thing's a spiral deal.
Mm.
I think they think that don't tell them
within the spiral,
get the eddies right,
which of the galaxies and the
irregularities and stuff,
but the whole Shebang is also spinning
the multiverse ideas like legit
scientists.
Talk about that now.
That that,
that there might be different for that.
Number two universes.
Yes,
I agree with that and there's so much
more sense.
What makes some kind of like the people
that go out of that's crazy,
but the universe,
it's crazy.
It's crazy.
It's crazy that you look out and you see
forever.
That's crazy.
That's really fucking crazy.
And when you look up
hanging out,
you're sitting on the side of a planet,
you're in the middle of the whole thing,
right?
Yeah.
You're in the middle of this soup of,
of reality.
But to think that that's crazy,
but that's as crazy as it gets.
Like says who,
why would,
why would you think this fucking the
infinite numbers of these things out
there that were just a part of something
that's so big you like,
if you looked at all of the Zeros on
that number,
you wouldn't even be able to wrap your
head around it.
You'd be like,
what?
What's a billion?
How many zeroes is that?
How many billions is this?
How many trillions isn't a billion?
And,
but there's no way that they,
it's too much.
There's this enigma thing.
I love it so much and it's talking about
it.
It has to do with why we haven't seen
aliens yet.
The fermi paradox.
Yes.
Yeah.
I think that's it.
The fermi paradox is like questioning
why?
Because there's so many different life.
I mean,
some different plants it could
potentially support life is like if
there's 100 billion galaxies or hundreds
of billion,
each one has a hundreds of billions of
stars.
How many of those have habitable planets
and if,
if so,
why haven't they contact?
Yes.
Yeah,
and like the math is overwhelming that
either we're the first or they kill all
the comers.
Hmm.
Or or there we're like,
or we turn inward
and go into the,
yeah.
What's the turn inward turning toward is
the,
the idea that we all go virtual and then
we become some sort of a symbiotic thing
connected to this,
this hive mind,
this real electronic reality.
I can't handle self driving cars.
I can't do that.
No,
I can't.
I'm not.
Am I?
Yes,
I am.
How could you dot.
Self driving?
Cars are real.
They're here and they suck right now.
They're killed a couple of people.
That's insane.
There's like five of them on the road
and they've already killed someone.
There's a lot of them on the road.
Yeah.
No,
I feel extremely unsafe about that.
I reject that with every fiber of my
being.
I drive my own car.
Good for you kind of car.
You drive a Mercedes,
do you rich check on their partying.
Hardy.
We're getting deep.
We're going deep.
Um,
I think they'll get it down.
They'll get the autonomous car down.
The real problem is going to be the
thrill and the excitement of freedom.
Just getting in your car,
turn the key and just going,
I'm good dude.
You can't do that anymore.
That's gonna.
That's gonna be a real thing that's
going to be one day.
No,
I mean not feels
extremely threatening as an American.
I feel like America to me is about big,
long roads and freedom.
Yeah.
Go where I want when I want kind of
thing.
Yeah.
If you've got the goods,
you can start a business there or
whatever it is.
That to me is America is the,
the,
I don't want to be locked into little
channels,
going all 20 miles an hour,
you know,
like I need,
do you want to be able to accelerate?
I consider driving kind of an art form.
It's kind of an art thing.
It's like a sport.
You be an activity and I don't want to
relinquish that to be like a thing on a
factory line.
Well you might get lucky and die before
it becomes mandatory.
No,
not at all.
no,
no.
That doesn't dovetail nicely with my
idea that they're going to discover
something that lets me live 500 years
cause I've decided that's exact perfect
life span for me.
For me personally,
not for everyone.
Would you think that you'll still be
getting after it when you like 450 years
old?
They'll have,
they'll have hormones for that.
They'll have everything.
Just we'll have everything for that.
Have you juiced up large physical
envelope will be okay.
It's the psychology.
Can you not go mad?
You might go mad.
Well it depends on if everyone else is
living 500 years.
Even then
before we were talking about if you
found out that you were going to live
this life over again every time,
like infinitely.
What'd you be able to handle it?
No,
but why you handle it now?
You live in right now?
No.
Would you be conscious that this was
your fifth two and half the time we take
someone's word for it back to the
Matrix,
neo is come back like five times.
He still can't get it right,
right.
But if someone came up to you right now
and said,
Liz,
I'm going to give you the reality of
existence,
the reality of existences.
You will do this life an infinite number
of times until you get it right and
you're never going to get it right.
So you just going to keep living this
life over and over again,
hopefully fucking up less and less each
time,
but most likely you're going to still
fuck up and you just going to keep doing
the same thing.
He'd be like,
no fucking way.
But if someone says,
do you want to end your life right now?
You'd be like,
no,
I love my life.
When you were on that plane and your
whole body was shaking,
you're like,
I want to stay alive.
I don't want to die.
So why don't you want to stay alive and
just keep doing it over and over and
over and over?
Well,
is there transcendence,
is there a goal?
If there's a goal I can get with it.
So transcendent meaning we evolve hogs
day.
You know that wonderful movie?
Yes.
Not that movie.
Great movie.
I looked that like like top 10 for me.
Okay.
You got to watch some other movies then.
But I love dumb nineties eighties
movies.
I like a lot of them to genre that I
really like.
I mean like blues brothers might be top
five easily for me.
Christmas vacations,
good movie.
I haven't seen that one.
But yes,
you're feeling me.
Okay.
So if there's,
if there's something that you evolve
into,
I can live my life over many times and
strive to be better at it,
but if there's no point to it all and I
just have to keep living over and over
and going to high school again and again
and again.
No.
Well don't you think that human beings
overall are evolving?
Yes,
I think so.
I didn't even,
besides,
I think even our trials and tribulations
and the things that go sideways,
they revealed sideways is an option to
us and gets us back on track.
I have an expression that my mother
loves onward and sideways.
That's good.
Kind of gets you up in the morning when
you were like,
I can't do it anymore.
Yeah,
I like that and I like the idea of,
I'm very into,
as we sort of evolve.
Speaking of Ufo conferences,
I was driven in the back of Rick Ruben's
Bentley.
When I first moved to La.
My friend Nora was friends with him and
he drove us to Ufo conference and I just
remember sitting in the back of this
huge Bentley and he wouldn't talk to me
at all like I was like not of interest
enough to,
I kept sort of poking my head up to the
front seat to like try to contribute to
the conversation.
Like yeah,
no,
he just like ignored everything I said
and they were talking about the
evolution of human consciousness at this
crazy UFO conference.
It was pretty funny.
It was very organized.
It was just like any like NAM or
something.
It was like anything.
Yeah,
they have some good ones,
you know,
there,
there's a business in it though.
That's the real issue with all the UFO
stuff is that there's a business is that
you get to a point where people realize
you could,
you could make a lot of profit if you
just start talking about Ufos are
talking about extra terrestrial invaders
that are inevitably coming and when and,
and then everything gets murky.
Know it gets real murky.
It's kind like who's who's being one
science and well you need to approach
it.
It's just,
it's not always pure.
You know,
like there's some people that look at it
and that are like real researchers.
Like this is a bunch of them that try to
figure out what the fuck is going on.
And they make a lot of sense,
you know,
and they're,
they're trying to figure it out but they
don't,
they don't point to anything in
particular and say this,
this little fetus,
this is an alien baby and we're going to
use genes to prove it.
Like,
you know,
they found that little baby with a big
head,
just a baby,
just a deformed baby.
But what they're really looking for is
aerial phenomenon,
right?
That's
Ariel phenomenon is one.
But phenomena.
The problem isn't a phenomenon.
Phenomena.
Yeah.
The problem is we don't know who stuffed
that is.
Right.
If it's ours,
it's flying around.
They don't tell you about it.
If it's some drones at the government's
working on cut,
that kind of maneuverability,
why aren't they using it?
What kind of maneuverability?
You convinced they have a,
they can move great speeds at odd angles
is what I understand.
Yeah.
I don't see us.
I mean,
they couldn't get here.
Well,
here's the thing,
they couldn't get here unless they were
able to actually like tesseract what
does that word tesseract from wrinkle in
time.
Like a girl book that was out now.
Right?
It's a movie.
I haven't seen the movie,
but it's nice flag.
Get my box set.
So they fold.
They full time horizon.
Ah,
no,
but I'm sure I'm familiar with it.
That's fucking movies.
Scary space.
Who's in that movie?
Laurence Fishburne and a bunch of other
people.
Sam,
the guy from Jurassic Park.
English gentlemen.
Uh dammit.
I want to say Harris with the son's
name.
Like the older guy.
The grandfather?
No,
the one who was Sam Neill.
Sam Neil.
He was one of the scientists,
one of the top scientists.
They went there with Laura dern.
He was like Laura durrance boyfriend.
He's English.
Yes.
Pretty sure theory is there's a
gentleman that's the event horizon.
English accent.
Yeah.
It doesn't mean maybe he's just so
proper.
I think he's English.
That'll blow my mind.
The movie's bad ass though.
It's one of the best horror slash
science fiction movies ever.
They combined like a demonic movie with
space.
It was demons in space.
Okay.
I like this.
Yeah.
The aliens are actually demons
sort of.
They punched through a wormhole in order
to travel this far and when they did,
they opened up a passage to hell
straight the dimension.
Tom.
Tom Don't paint well.
Hell being what we would do to extra
terrestrials.
I mean,
think about who we are to an alien
civilization.
Let's just say they're peaceful and
they're not.
I mean like imagine us,
although we'd probably be like so
evolutionarily backward,
right?
It would probably be like if we had a
giant hamster wheel and visited a crazy
arm chimps and you're like Whoa,
slow the fuck.
You know.
They probably would be really aware that
we're super violent,
would shoot at them and shit.
They probably would do something to slow
that down.
No,
officially high.
Like I can feel it.
It just happen to me.
No,
there's no doubt.
Right.
So.
Okay.
Have you ever been to one of my
concerts?
No.
Does that bum you out?
No,
not at all.
I was going to ask you,
cause I was assuming it was pretty early
on.
I'm going out,
I'm going to plugging myself now,
but I'm going out and I'm playing all
these songs that I haven't played ever
really live that I wrote.
Grab that microphone.
Sorry.
Stay with me.
I'm going to whisper.
When are you performing out here?
Soon
I will be like eight shows.
It'll come and go.
Kind of like a shooting star through the
sky.
What are you going to be here happening
now joe?
Get down here.
I'm sure June I'm in,
but it's kind of
an interesting thing if you play stuff
that is from from a really long time ago
and it was pretty rudimentary on stage,
can you trick it out with a base?
Can you trick it out with drums?
Can you go back and like reinvent your
early work?
Do you think that that would be like,
would that upset an old fan?
You mean if an old fan wanted to hear it
the way it was?
Like if you had an acoustic version,
did they want me to just exactly hit
exactly how I played at?
Probably right.
Are Don't think that you can leave that
up to vote
cause I was thinking it would help my
voice to be a stoner since I was a
stoner back.
So you're thinking about getting into
being a stone now.
I might,
you make it good stoner sitting around
and talking about black holes and shit.
Perfect dose.
You believe in ghosts.
Like all that shit sober though.
Yeah.
That's the scary part.
Well I think most people do.
I don't think most people that are
watching those go shows are high.
No.
Yeah,
the Internet is like the paranormal.
Oh,
well it's library things that people are
curious about and they're fun.
Like if ghosts were real,
it'd be fun.
It'd be awesome.
You know?
It wouldn't be fun if they weren't real
and be like,
oh,
you mean all those shows where you've
never been scared by ghost.
You've never actually like even thought
I've definitely been scared.
I never thought animals.
No.
I've been through the comedy store,
which was been,
apparently a bunch of people get
murdered there.
When Bugsy Siegel owned it,
he used to be Ciro's nightclub and a lot
of people that worked there,
apparently I've seen ghosts.
Like even my friends told me they seen
goes.
I don't know.
I Dunno.
What did they say?
Did they said they saw ghosts?
I mean,
maybe they were talking to human look.
I've never seen an actual human effort.
Some have told me they were grabbed.
Carla boasts that he was grabbed and
dragged.
He was in a dark room and something
grabbed him and dragged him on the
ground and then ran through the place
and slam the door outside.
You're kidding.
That's what he said.
Could it have been a person?
Could have been for sure.
The people are real,
you know,
it's more likely a person.
He's in a pitch black room.
It might have been one of his asshole
friends side to grab him cause he's
probably drunk off his ass laying down
there.
Like I think you had a fight with his
wife or something like that.
Went to the comic store.
I was like fuck this.
I'm,
I lie here,
I'm gonna make it.
I'm going to be a big man.
And then something like came into the
room,
he tells the whole story on stage.
It's really kind of interesting the way
he tells it.
Cause he,
he's very dramatic and goes through the
whole detail of it.
But I've talked to several waitstaff,
waitresses,
managers that have seen ghost there.
Comics who've seen ghosts there.
And,
but again,
people were full of Shit.
Right?
You get a hundred people,
one of them's a fucking moron.
And that one out of a hundred might tell
you some goofy ass fucking store cause
they want to be special.
But what happened to you that made you
scared?
Oh,
normal stuff.
Just being in the dark.
I'm just freaked out to be.
Yeah.
I'm more scared of animals than anything
else.
The real things,
you know?
I'm scared of real shit.
Oh yeah.
Huge giant.
I've shot a moose.
I stumbled.
You shot a moose kill in the first time.
Yeah,
I ate it could for you.
that's true.
Hunting.
Yeah.
Well,
it's the way to do it.
Fucking huge.
They're like,
um,
they don't even look like a real animal.
The first time I saw him,
one in British Columbia,
it looked like it was like a scene from
Jurassic Park.
We pulled,
we pulled the car over and we rolled the
windows down.
We're like,
what the fuck?
Look at that thing is so big.
I think I could walk under it and clear.
You might be able to really think like
their legs are,
you know,
you a little duck.
Maybe it's the worst.
They're so big.
Doesn't even make sense.
Like you feel like you could drive a car
under them.
Yeah.
They're enormous.
They're the redwoods of deer.
Yeah.
Crazy animal grows giant doors on its
head every year and then they fall off
after the done breeding,
the horns fall off and they regrow
again.
Did you,
did you have to wait for a long time to
get it?
Yeah,
we were.
We were there for like five days and we
got it on the fifth day.
The fourth or the fifth day?
Yeah,
same animal.
You saw it.
No,
no,
we didn't seem one.
We're looking at,
there's a lot of wolves up there.
Are you allowed to shoot the wolf?
Yeah.
They tried to get you to kill as many as
you can.
I didn't.
I don't want to,
but if you're up there,
they give you an unlimited tag for
wolves.
You could shoot 30 walls,
but you won't,
you'll never get 30 of them.
They're smart as shit.
But we did come across a baby moose.
I got eaten by a wolf.
Ooh,
it's crazy.
A pack of wolves was hair everywhere.
That was the most surprising thing.
It's just fucking hair.
I didn't think there would be hair
everywhere,
but I'm like,
of course they're going to kill this
thing.
They have to chew off the hair.
Oh yeah.
Spit it out.
Right.
Every meal,
every meal.
And animal eats has like all this
correct.
Like the snow one preparing it there.
No knives and forks.
They can't lay in their shit
to see ropes of hair and their shit.
Dude,
girl.
Yeah.
They don't just eat the meat like nice
and clean like a bowl and chopped up
meat.
No,
they're eating the hair.
Everything.
Yeah.
I used to look at those like wild horse
videos and they would show that pack of
wild horses and I would try to think
like,
is it better?
Maybe it's better to be like stabled and
in a clean with Nice,
you know,
sawdust or whatever in your pen.
Like maybe it's not so bad to be a kept
animal.
I'm not sure.
I'd like to be a wild horse.
I mean,
it seems really romantic,
but would it really be fun?
It's a great rolling stone song.
I think what it is is,
uh,
they're,
they're not the same thing that they
used to be.
They're not the same thing.
You're right.
Yeah.
They've been domesticated for so long.
It's not even the same animal,
really.
Do you know what to see what that
genetic memory thing you're talking?
Yeah.
Do you know scrub bullous?
Ever heard of that expression?
Scramble.
Scrub bowls are wild.
Um,
domestic cattle,
domestic cattle that's broken down
barriers and gone wild and has lived in
the wild for several generations to
change their form.
They look different.
They look,
they're much more muscular.
They're freaky looking multicolored.
Sometimes they have grow giant antlers
are giant horns rather.
And it,
Australia has a real issue with them and
they're super,
super aggressive.
When you think about bull riding,
people ride bowls and the
go fucking crazy.
That's what a bull does.
Bowls are ruthless motherfuckers.
They're just out there trying to have
sex with cow and anything that gets
anywhere near them,
they'll fuck up because they're giant.
So these things just roam wild and there
are different animal now and people hunt
them.
It's very strange.
That is a,
that's a wild animal.
These horses are still the same form as
when people domesticated them.
They just got loose.
And so they're just running around
trying to find something to eat.
They're not real wild.
Wild.
They're wild.
Horses are not native to North America.
Oh Wow.
Yeah.
They were brought in to North America.
The native Americans did not have
horses.
We brought them in from Europe.
I did not know that.
Yeah.
Well what's crazy is horse is originated
in North America many,
many eons ago,
but then died off in North America but
prospered overseas in different places
like possibly when across the bering
land mash and all these different places
where horses evolved and became zebras
and all these other different animals
like and then they,
the Europeans brought the horse back to
North America.
But the horse originated in North
America but then died off.
So these wild horses,
they're just domestic horses.
They got free.
So it is kind of shit.
Yeah,
it's kind of shitty.
They don't really,
they probably like if you see a really
well taken care of horace,
they don't seem to mind it.
Like if there's a place up here that has
a stable and people ride their horses,
people come by and pet the horses.
The horses seems so chill.
They don't seem to mind it at all.
Like,
if it's a loved horse in there taking
care of and you know they're just
treated well and fed well,
they don't,
it doesn't seem to mind.
How do they not mind that hugely heavy
saddle and that hugely heavy human
beings only hugely heavy to you.
The amount of so happy that a horse has.
Do you deal with that?
How about what does a big horse way?
Thousand Pounds.
2000 pounds.
It's like you remember when your son was
really little,
he put them on your shoulders,
didn't really bother you.
What it's like.
And then think of the mass that a horse
carries around just a bone structure and
the muscle,
this fucking thing that can jump over
huge stacks.
A logs with a person on its back.
It is pretty incredible.
Yeah,
they're insane.
So what we are,
you know,
if we had to carry a purse around yeah,
that was fucking suck.
Yeah.
Because we got squishy discs in our back
and our muscles give out and we cramp up
and you know,
we're,
we're in stupid fuck
shoes and like a horse can carry a
person for a long time.
I feel a little bad for them.
Yeah.
They probably shouldn't do it when
they're tired.
Battled a horse.
I don't ride horses.
No.
You have to pull this strap like really
tightly around their barrel chest.
Right?
Yeah.
Cause they do this thing where they,
when they can tell that you're saddling
them,
they like stick their bellies out.
Oh.
To try to get to sell some space so that
when you let go they go like this and
they're more
comfortable.
So you literally have to like Yank this
thing and you're like,
ah,
on that.
Otherwise you'll start to slip when
you're riding,
you'll just start to fall like slowly.
I mean it sucks.
That's why they're always fighting when
you were on the trail because were like
I said,
to just fart all the time anyway.
I think they probably do.
I just made that up.
I don't want him to sound like I didn't
want to talk about,
but you're squeezing them.
Done.
It's turnips.
But they spoke like if they saw a wolf
they'd go nuts.
Oh yeah.
I spoke at a garbage can.
Do you know?
That's why cowboy boots are made that
way.
Where your feet going,
I'm loose and then they have the,
the heel,
all that is so that the heel slides on
that thing that your foot sticks in.
What's that thing called?
Startup stirrup.
Your foot slides in and locks on that
stirrup with the heel and then if you
get knocked off,
the foot should just comes off.
You don't get dragged.
Oh,
I'll give your foot.
If you have like hiking boots on with
like 17 eye holes and you get that bitch
tie down laced in and you shove them
into those stirrups.
If that fucking horse starts bucking and
you get knocked loose,
you're going to get dragged and kicked
to death.
You're going to be hanging on by your
foot.
It's going to install it on your head.
As you're running around,
you're gonna bounce you off rocks and
shit.
But if you're in one of them cowboy
boots,
you feet just come right out.
I am now only going to wear cowboy boots
if you're riding.
The horse should only wear cowboy boots.
I haven't been,
but that's why they're so slippery.
That's why they come right off to their
goofy smart.
It is for horse riding.
Yeah,
but like people that don't get that and
try to wear like big ass fucking
mountaineering boots and ride a horse
like,
yeah.
I don't think anyone can fit a big ass
mountain every mood in his church.
This was a real issue with people that
go mountain hunting.
I always thought cowboy boots are for
snakes.
That's why they were like so thick.
I bet that that's it too.
I bet that they had to go up high enough
to say that a strike wouldn't get.
Yeah.
Yeah,
that makes sense.
That's probably a factor too,
but there's definitely a factor.
Like the way the heels constructed is
that your stirrup sits right in the heel
and the way your foot just comes right
off
and the way the toe goes up,
it would just stay in.
You'd go flying or,
exactly.
It's really smart,
right?
What's the point of tears?
Really smart tips.
He gets stuck up there.
He foot goes flying out and you're done.
I know that was a very vivid,
now that I'm high,
like to imagine my head bouncing along
the trail behind the horse.
Back your head cracking off rocks.
She got try to stay conscious.
Grabbing your head,
your head,
your hand gets smashed in the ram.
Anything.
You're just a rag doll.
Ah Yeah,
exactly.
Declan.
Oh you're awfully silent over there.
Does he ever,
he talks all the time.
He's a good talker.
Really.
Jamie?
Smart Guy.
But we could wrap this up if you like.
She had to be out of here.
I thought 45.
Oh Shit.
She probably get out of here.
That did just by did you drive?
No,
no.
Someone getting?
Yeah.
Okay.
Um,
when can people find out where you're
playing and when you're playing live,
what's the best way?
Is it your website?
Yes.
Liz phair.com.
Okay.
I think
people find it.
Go look for it.
And your collection sold out already.
Damn.
Look at you.
That went exceedingly fast and I was
terrified by it.
I had like a complete breakdown and
couldn't be on twitter for three days
cause I was so shocked at how fast they
went.
I just nervous.
I don't know.
It just,
it became very real,
very fast
when the box that's coming out I think
is May 4th,
which may the fourth be with you and
also with you.
I'm very excited about that.
Awesome.
I'm going to buy it.
It's like a compendium.
It's going,
there's my origin story.
Basically you wrap this up.
If I kick the bucket,
we're good.
And we know where I came from.
It's all like collected and beautiful
packaging.
Um,
super cool.
That's fair.
This was a lot of fun.
It wasn't really a lot of fun.
This is the best.
Let's make all interviews like this.
All right.
Thank you very much gentlemen,
by everybody.
I love.